et tous les citoyens qui ont choisi de
se rendre aux urnes et ont ainsi
témoigné de leur attachement à la
démocratie municipale à titre plus
personnel je saisis évidemment cette
occasion pour remercier les havrais et
les havrais qui m'ont placé en tête des
suffrages avec plus de 43 % le taux
d'abstention élevé que nous enregistrons
témoignent cependant de l'inquiétude
grandissante de nos concitoyens face à
l'épidémie qui nous frappe
selon as c'est la raison pour laquelle
demain comme nous l'avons fait jusqu'à
présent sept en prenant compte c'est en
prenant en compte l'avis des autorités
sanitaires que nous nous organiserons
pour le second tour je réunirai à
nouveau en début de semaine le conseil
scientifique puis je consulterai les
représentants des forces politiques
c'est dans une transparence totale
en prenant en compte les recommandations
sanitaires et je l'espère dans un esprit
de consensus républicain que nous
prendrons les mesures nécessaires
par ailleurs le gouvernement est
mobilisé en permanence pour préciser et
compléter les décisions que nous avons
prises hier avec le président de la
république dans les prochains jours
c'est la crise sanitaire qui continuera
à nous mobiliser l'ensemble des membres
du gouvernement prépare les mesures
sanitaires économiques sociales
scolaires et plus généralement toutes
les mesures qui doivent nous permettre
de faire face et de surmonter cette
crise je vous remercie
et voilà donc pour l'intervention
d'edouard philippe ce soir edouard
philippe qui se présentent au havre et
qui a obtenu ce soir près de 43% ce sont
les estimations bien sûr de ce scrutin
à la une ce soir une une très faible
participation pour ce premier tour des
élections municipales
en france près de 39 des inscrits
avaient voté à 17h ses 16 points de
moins qu'il ya six ans un premier tour
maintenue sur fond d'incertitudes sur la
tenue du second tour puisque la france
risque de passer également en
confinement total dans les prochaines
heures
candidats et partis politiques réduisent
leur soirée électorale certains
appellent report ce soir et puis nombre
nombre record de décès quotidiens en
italie fermeture des frontières en
allemagne les simulations des
épidémiologistes sont alarmantes en
l'absence de mesures radicales de
prévention après la fermeture des public
des lieux publics non indispensables
hier les tribunaux français seront clos
à partir de lundi le confinement total
et l'interdiction de se déplacer est
envisagé ce soir
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans cette
édition spéciale élections municipales
avec l'incertitude bien sûr d'un second
tour ce soir on a entendu edouard
philippe le premier ministre s'est
exprimé il affirme qu'un conseil
scientifique et des représentants des
partis politiques vont se réunir dès
lundi pour tenter de faire le point pour
savoir si le second tour sera maintenue
edouard philippe qui veut pas un
consensus républicain olivier alors tous
les cas effectivement un taux est très
faible taux de très faible de
participation dans ce contexte de
pandémie coronavirus à les bureaux de
vote des grandes villes ont fermé à 20
heures
on va tout de suite faire le point avec
notre reporter mona a moulé l'or au
ministère de l'intérieur à mona bonsoir
alors la première information du jour un
taux de participation en chute libre
il ya exactement olivier là on a
plusieurs chiffres dans plusieurs
grandes villes mais attention ils sont à
prendre avec des pincettes car ils vont
changer tout au long de cette soirée
prenez par exemple dans la ville du
havre edouard philippe récolterez 43%
des intentions de vote devant jean-paul
lecoq du parti communiste français à
perpignan par exemple louis aliot du
rassemblement national serait devant le
candidat pujol de l'est républicain avec
33 % contre 18 % à lille martine aubry
du ps devant serait lé candidat europe
écologie et les verts et lrm avec 30%
encore une fois je répète ces chiffres
vont changer tout au long de cette
soirée il est également ces chiffres de
l'abstention qui sont extrêmement
impressionnant qui sont également
susceptibles de changer avec 53,5 % et
56 % selon ipsos encore une fois contre
36,1 45 % en 2014 on voit qu'il ya une
grande différence un fossé entre ces
deux chiffres
il faut savoir que sept premiers ce
premier tour et ces élections
municipales elles ont été largement est
décriée par là par certaines
personnalités politiques que ce soient
de l'opposition ou de la majorité qui
demandait un report de ces élections
il ya également les français qui se sont
exprimés via les réseaux sociaux et qui
ont manifesté leur mécontentement à
l'aide d'un hashtag qui disait je n'irai
pas voter
le corps médical également à merci mona
bout dès lors en direct de la place
beauvau à paris et on va apprendre tout
de suite
le direct avec louis aliot qui s'exprime
ce soir je vous donne rendez vous pour
une autre communication ne connaissant
pas encore les décisions qui seront
prises par le premier ministre et le
président de la république concernant la
vie sociale la vie civile et concernant
le deuxième tour de cette élection
municipale
mais très honnêtement et en conscience
je ne vois pas comment pourrait se
dérouler un deuxième tour à cette
élection municipale je remercie mes
colistiers mes équipes militantes toutes
celles et ceux qui m'ont soutenu depuis
déjà deux laonnois et qui ce soir
regarder la situation avec évidemment
beaucoup de satisfaction par rapport aux
résultats obtenus mais aussi beaucoup de
craintes par rapport à la situation que
nous vivons
je demande évidemment à ce que les
autorités départementales nous tiennent
informé le mieux possible de l'avancé
des décisions qui sont prises et je
pense affectueusement à celles et ceux
qui sont ce soir touchées par la maladie
à leurs proches et à tous ceux qui sont
à leur chevet merci et je suis prêt à
répondre à vos questions
et voilà donc pour l'intervention de
louis aliot le candidat du rassemblement
national à perpignan qui est aurait
obtenu ce soir 33 % selon les premières
estimations louis aliot du rassemblement
national qui succède à marine le pen qui
s'est exprimé d'abord sur cette
situation de coronavirus louis aliot qui
demandent également la non tenue d'un
second tour marine le pen elle a demandé
justement est ce que les maires sortants
qui aurait obtenu une majorité absolue
au premier tour
n'ai pas besoin de ce second tour donc
validé en tout cas là laval est là la
réélection de certains maires l'élection
des maires qui serait arrivé au premier
tour thomas bonne et on va faire le
point justement parce qu'une polémique
la polémique avait déjà commencé avant
ce premier tour sur la demande de report
des élections ont vraisemblablement là
tout le monde semble d'accord pour qu'un
second tour ne soit pas possible a
priori absolument vous l'avez dit donc
marine le pen qui demande à ce que le
second tour ne se tienne pas c'est le
cas également de yannick jadot un patron
d'europe écologie les verts on a appris
également que le parti radical de gauche
demandaient le report de ce second tour
est déjà ce samedi soir il y avait eu
des demandes en ce sens demande sur
twitter notamment de la part de
président de région c'est le cas par
exemple de xavier bertrand président de
la région haute france qui écrit sur
twitter sur twitter qui écrivait ce
samedi j'ai demandé compte tenu des
décisions du premier ministre le report
des municipales
même chose pour renaud muselier
président de la région sud il était
légitime de maintenir le souffle
démocratique de notre nation mais ce
soir face aux faits devient raisonnable
cohérent et même nécessaire de reporter
le scrutin municipal
c'est le cas également pour hervé morin
président de la région normandie ou
encore de carole delga présidente de la
région occitanie on a également pu noter
que gilles simeoni président du conseil
exécutif de corse demandé lui aussi le
report et puis il y à des personnalités
publiques du domaine de la santé qui ont
également demandé ce report c'est le cas
de rémi salomon le président de la
commission médicale d'établissement de
l'ap-hp qui a tout simplement écrit sur
twitter n'allez pas voter éviter les
contacts amende de m on voit que la
pression s'accentue de mètres ils ont qu
un maître dont il ça et on voit que la
pression s'accentue avec un casque est
évidemment pour les constitutionnalistes
est il possible que le premier tour soit
maintenue et que second tour soit
reporté c'est ce qui va se jouer
certainement dans les prochaines heures
avec notamment je vous le rappelle donc
cette consultation en début de semaine
au tour d'edouard philippe d'experts
scientifiques pour faire le point sur la
tenue de ce contrat situation inédite ce
soir merci thomas et on va continuer à
en parler en ce report avec gérard
filoche il est syndicaliste et ancien
inspecteur du travail gérard filoche
bonsoir
alors ce report du second tour semble
désormais inévitable pour vous qu'est ce
qu'il veut vraiment edouard philippe
parce que si j'ai bien compris au
premier tour edouard filet puis dans une
situation difficile et il va être battu
au 2e tour probablement s'il y en a
alors est-ce qu'il est intéressé pour
des raisons sanitaires ou pour des
raisons politiques
la question reste un peu ouverte moi je
suis préoccupé d'abord par les eaux
sanitaires bien sûr mais moi je crois
que le gouvernement devrait mettre 5
milliards sur la table tout de suite
pour les hôpitaux 5 milliards pour
augmenter les salaires des infirmières
des aides soignantes des mets des
médecins qui travaillent trop pour
recruter des effectifs il suffit pas de
dire que on va faire revenir les
infirmières retraitées combien on va les
payer
moi j'ai passé du temps à l'hôpital
hélas pour moi au début du mois de
janvier je voyais les infirmières qui
faisait 12 heures et qui était payée
très 150 euros l'hôpital a été cassée
depuis deux ans il ya une grave à
l'hôpital depuis un an jamais macro n'a
répondu à cela il n'a pas entendu madame
busin non plus et maintenant il y parle
de pandémie mais si les hôpitaux peuvent
pas faire face à la pandémie
c'est leur faute et il faut qu'il la
répare tout de suite 5 milliards pour
les hôpitaux parce que l'eau reste les
considérations tacticienne manoeuvrière
électorale ça ça passe après cette
réponse en matière de santé et je vois
pas pourquoi j'arrive pas à comprendre
la politique de macron il ya quinze
jours il y avait un comité de défense
ils ont pour la première fois posé la
question du report des municipales et au
lieu de parler du report des municipales
il ya quinze jours qu'un jour ils ont
fait le 49-3 je comprends pas la
cohérence de tout ça c'est pas
l'impression de macron se préoccupe en
premier de la santé des français
j'ai plutôt l'impression qu'ils
s'occupent d'eux comment s'en sortir et
sans aucun doute edouard philippe aussi
alors maintenant si to play les
autorités disent qu'il faut un
confinement complet il faut un
confinement complet bien sûr mais encore
une fois fois pouvoir faire des tests
j'ai entendu monsieur olivier
verrons ce soir minizoo la santé dit on
fait 2000 thèse par jour j'ai bien
compris 2000 seulement on n'a pas des
moyens en france d'en faire plus est ce
que ce chiffre est vrai pourquoi n'y
at-il pas immédiatement tout mis sur la
table pour faire plus de tests je sais
qu'on peut pas les faire pour tout le
monde on nous dit c'est impossible mais
on peut le faire pour un plus grand
nombre de gens qui sont touchés
on peut dépister un peu plus dès qu'il
ya course tout ça me semble comment vous
dire sans queue ni tête du point de vue
de la cohérence au plus haut niveau du
pouvoir pouvoir qui va décider de
reporter les élections
sauf que les laboratoires a pris ne sont
pas en mesure d'effectuer lé les faire à
l'hôpital jusqu'à présent gérard filoche
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ce
qu'a dit marine le pen madame madame 5,5
milliards allez-y madame amara dont j'ai
pas entendu marine le pen par les 2,5
milliards pour les pour les hôpitaux un
jeu quand on parle de questions sociales
en général marine le pen elle est plus
large moi je suis préoccupé par les
questions sociales je suis préoccupé par
les hospitaliers par les soignants les
aides soignantes les infirmières les
infirmiers les médecins tous ceux qui à
l'hôpital aujourd'hui se trouve compris
à la gorge et pour faut 5 milliards tout
de suite pas dans deux mois pendant
trois mois d'ailleurs macron si c'est
dans trois mois
ils m'ont tellement qui ne tiendra pas
donc il lâche tout de suite 5 milliards
qu'on trouve tous les moyens de
démultiplier la cac et le soin ya pas
que le coronavirus on sait bien il ya la
grippe bon des vieilles personnes sont
menacées par la grippe y ait encore plus
de morts est ce que je sais je ne suis
pas un scientifique par la grippe plutôt
que par le corona virus bon pour traiter
tous à l'hôpital est engorgé et donc
c'est d'abord prendre la question de
l'hôpital
la priorité absolue est de dire qu'est
ce qu'on y change comment on leur donne
les moyens débloquer 5 milliards pour
l'hôpital du coup gérard filoche au vu
d'une abstention très forte ce soir
comment est ce que on peut voir les
résultats de ce premier tour ce qu'il
faut les maintenir
et puis reporté un second tour comme
disait marine le pen écoutez moi je
regarde les résultats il ya quand même
pour ce qui est des macros nhien c'est
un effondrement par tous toute façon il
se cachait et les listes il les affiches
est pas leurs couleurs il faisait des
coalitions savait pas trop bon qu'est ce
qui se dégage comme première tendance
s'est pas encore facile à dire mais
enfin si on prend la ville comme le
havre
c'est une poussée pour la gauche unie
les écologistes viennent après ils ont
il ya des réserves de voir et le premier
mise qui quand même la figure de proue
de la politique menée depuis deux ans
est sur la sellette avec 43% il ne passe
pas au premier tour comme la dernière
fois il a perdu plus de 10% des voix et
le second tour est presque lui être
fatale moi je vois ça dans pas mal de
villes c'est dire que la wii à la gauche
unie ça marche
là où il ya une addition de force
politique qui ce qu elle coalisés puis
qui se dépasse là où les partis se
mettre d'accord et son rang dynamique ça
passe me semble-t-il
bon alors après je vois bien le le à
part la disparition de l'est mer la
menace du front national à perpignan et
je pense qu'il faut faire barrage à
monsieur aller au qinghai pas nouvelle
le plus 5000 habitants mais la question
c'est l'unité de la gauche il aurait dû
se faire là bas
et quand y'a pas l'unité de la gauche
évidemment il ya des menaces de ce type
alors je vous me demandez est-ce que ça
doit se faire la semaine prochaine
moi ce que je veux pas si vous me
permettez de le dire avec mes mots c'est
que mettront macron gagne du temps parce
que toute une partie de ce qui est bon
enfant c'est à cause de lui et les les
élections là seront pas de sanctionner
alors si vous gagnez du temps et si ça
ça puis effectivement soit une nécessité
de confinement général pour des raisons
sanitaires
bon ça va s'imposer c'est pas moi qui
décide mais alors juste que ce sera
gérable ths que c'est qu'on retrouve les
conditions du vote
est ce que justement le fait de ne pas
avoir de second tour tout en maintenant
les résultats du du premier ce que ça ne
va pas biaisé justement les les
résultats et le deuxième tour puisque on
aura déjà une une estimation des
premiers évidemment madame éviter les
huit mad évidemment madame c crève coeur
le choix démocratique est plus important
là on a un conflit de comment dirais-je
entre le sanitaire et la démocratie et
moi j'aime les deux les soins sanitaires
5 milliards pour les hôpitaux et j'aime
la démocratie c'est là que les élections
se tiennent régulièrement par exemple je
ne voudrais pas que macron regroupe
commune voulais au début les élections
municipales territoriales et régionales
parce qu'il avait l'intention de faire
ça vous savez c'était dans ses plans je
sais pas si c'est pas encore dans ses
plans caché dans le fond de sa tête
aujourd'hui avec ce qui se passe mais je
suis pas pour qu'il vienne une élection
groupée dans trois ans donc en vérité si
les élections municipales du deuxième
tour ne peuvent pas pour les raisons
sanitaires de confinement généralisé se
tenir dimanche prochain pour questionne
le plus tôt possible en partant des
résultats du premier je veux pas de
macron puisse échapper à la sanction
le président macron qui d'ailleurs avait
annoncé qui lui ne tirerai aucune leçon
national de ce scrutin est ce que vous y
croyez aujourd'hui à cette parole boyle
a bien tort parce que il ya des gens il
explique que les élections municipales
sont pas politiques mais sont politiques
tout est politique dans la vie même le
traitement de du confinement et des
décisions salutaires ces politiques et
mâcon et quand ils disent et je vous
échapper aux municipales mais excusez
moi je vais vous faire un retour en
arrière en 2014
françois hollande avait déjà commencé
une politique si mauvaise vais déjà
tellement commencé à travailler à la
gauche que ça a été un désastre pour le
parti socialiste aux municipales
s'étaient pas à cause des maires c'était
pâques aux conditions locales
c'était parce que les gens cherchent et
une sanction moi j'avais un cas j'avais
un ami qui était dans une petite ville
de luberon il était élu maire depuis
deux mandats il avait à ce moment-là
perdu 2,21 une voix comme on se connaît
dans une petite ville et étaient allés
voir ce qu'ils n'étaient pas venus voter
qu'ils s'étaient abstenus
et il lui avait dit oh mais tu sais
philippe c'est pas pour toi nous on
t'aime bien comme maire nous on voulait
dire à hollande que ça allait pas alors
fini puis répond db c'est moi qui était
battu et effectivement ça se passe
toujours comme ça c'est à dire que quand
vous avez des élections régionales aussi
en 2004 rappelez-vous 2003 fillon impose
une erreur la casse des retraites une
première fois et en 2004 la gauche gagne
20 régions sur 22
c'était pas à cause du mérite des
présidents de région c'était parce que
les gens se vengerait en 2004 sur 20
régions sur 22 ce que la politique de
fillon et de raf raffarin lors avait
fait contre leur retraite donc il ya
toujours un lien entre les élections
locales et les élections nationales sur
ce village ces élections municipales
maison cache
oui j'ai rappelé que ce soit de
particulier les socialistes tout comme
ces critiques la vie des gens les
socialistes tout comme les républicains
espèrent en tout cas que ces élections
on être pour une renaissance après les
les résultats que l'on connaît des
dernières élections ont laminé ces deux
grands partis principaux il y à il ya
quelques temps vous pensez que ce sera
l'occasion pour eux de revivre de
renaître
mettez pas les républicains et les
socialistes ont le même plan parce que
si on prend l'exemple des dépositions de
l'un et l'autre sur les retraites des
républicains sont pour la retraite à 65
ans et maintenant les socialistes je
m'en réjouis ont pris position contre la
retraite par points donc il ne faut pas
mettre sur le même plan ce qui est en
train de se passer dans la vie politique
dans la conscience de millions de gens
c'est d'eux qu'il refuse la casse
sociale de macron il refuse les
retraites qu'ils les casses il refuse la
classe du chômage
d'ailleurs ça serait bien que le 1er
avril prochain il ne soit pas appliqué
la loi sur le chômage qui est passé à
part en vigueur à partir du 1er novembre
et ensuite les gens sont pas content non
plus de la case de la sncf
il se rappelle trop de la casse du code
du travail donc tout ça est en train de
maturer dont les consciences macron le
sait il a ça en face de lui et c'est
plutôt à gauche que la solution parce
que nous on va pas avoir un résultat ce
que je viens de dire en train dans un
débat entre les républicains et le pen
et puis
les maquereaux dhien le vrai choix c'est
entre la droite et la gauche
rien n'a pas d'autre dans ce pays il
n'ya pas de milieu il n'y a pas de
centre et la gauche c'est la gauche unie
et moi je milite pour soi la gauche
sunnite
si le parti socialiste vous êtes dedans
je m'en réjouis
qu'ils viennent pas être hégémoniques
mais qui se fait dans et dans un certain
nombre de corps en france il est dedans
et dans un certain nombre d'autres cas
il est un peu trop hégémonie c'est pas
trop la chose en main il faudrait une
vraie unité comment dirais-je dialoguer
démocratique de la gauche une majorité
qui respecte toutes ses composantes qui
les unit fille et créer une dynamique
pour pouvoir gagner
après les avancées du premier tour au
deuxième tour quelle que soit sa date
merci beaucoup gérard filoche d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rtl france
ce soir et magali à hénin beaumont le
maire n steeve briois a été réélu lui
dès le premier tour informations qui
proviennent son entourage plus tôt la
présidente du rassemblement national
s'était rendue aux bureaux de vote dans
une ville quasiment déserte
un marine le pen a par ailleurs annoncé
qu'il fallait considérer comme acquise
les victoires au premier tour et
reporter le second écoutez la compte
tenu des témoignages qui remontent de
tous les services hospitaliers et de
l'expérience que nous devons tirer de la
situation chez nos voisins le second
tour n'aura manifestement pas lieu
compte tenu de l'aggravation prévisible
de l'épidémie il faut donc considérer
comme acquise les nombreuses élections
qui ont vu les candidats être élu au
premier tour et reporter les autres qui
devront se tenir dans quelques mois
quand l'épidémie sera jugulée et au
havre selon des résultats définitifs ce
soir le premier ministre edouard
philippe est donc arrivé en tête du
premier tour avec 43 1,60 pour cent des
suffrages il arrive donc devant la liste
conduite par le député du parti
communiste français jean-paul lecoq qui
lui obtient 35,1 88% le premier ministre
qui s'est exprimé ce soir il a remercié
ses électeurs il a aussi déclaré que le
taux d'abstention de ce premier tour
démontrait
en tout cas l'incertitude des français
concernant le coronavirus edouard
philippe qui a également annoncé que le
gouvernement allait s'organiser dès le
début de la semaine prochaine pour le
second tour que d'autres mesures
pouvaient être prises en tout cas il va
concerner les experts et les leaders des
partis politiques écoutez le le taux
d'abstention élevé que nous enregistrons
témoignent cependant de l'inquiétude
grandissante de nos concitoyens face à
l'épidémie qui nous frappe c'est long
c'est la raison pour laquelle demain
comme nous l'avons fait jusqu'à présent
sept en prenant compte c'est en prenant
en compte l'avis des autorités
sanitaires que nous nous organiserons
pour le second tour je réunirai à
nouveau en début de semaine le conseil
scientifique puis je consulterai les
représentants des forces politiques
c'est dans une transparence totale
en prenant en compte les recommandations
sanitaires et je l'espère dans un esprit
de consensus républicain que nous
prendrons les mesures nécessaires et on
va partir en corse maintenant lille fait
partie des régions les plus touchées du
pays par le coronavirus et les électeurs
ont dans l'ensemble redoubler de
vigilance pour se rendre aux urnes
certains déplorent malgré tout le
maintien de ces élections dans un
contexte de crise sanitaire majeure
écouter ses réactions dans les bureaux
de vote d'âge action oui on y passe bien
sur mais bon si on est raisonnable et
conduit et consignes je pense que tout
devrait aller correctement ma j'ai tout
prévu parce que je préférais prendre mon
propos liquide plutôt que d'en prendre à
ceux qui en ont réellement besoin à
savoir les hôpitaux
voilà donc puisque les élections ont
lieu j'y suis mais je préférais qu'elle
soit reportée la situation en tant que
professionnels de la restauration je
trouve un petit peu dommageable qu'on
nous demande de fermer l'établissement
et qu'en même temps on autorise on
autoriser les élections celles ci
avaient un peu d'en passer complètement
à l'opposé
ces deux décisions qui sont à mon sens
est responsable et l'ancien garde des
sceaux rachida dati a voté 2
puis le 7e arrondissement où elle est
candidate à sa réélection
la maire sortante les républicains en
place depuis douze ans a voté en
respectant l aussi des les consignes
sanitaires
l'ancien ministre de la justice de
nicolas sarkozy est plutôt bien et est
plutôt bien positionné dans les sondages
pour ce premier tour en manque peut-être
d'alliés dans cette course pour briguer
le siège à l'hôtel de ville
et puis dans le 5e arrondissement de
paris la candidate agnès buzyn elle
s'est également rendue aux urnes ce
matin l'ex ministre de la santé est
donné en troisième position du premier
tour
agnès buzyn qui a annoncé exclure toute
alliance avec la candidate les
républicains rachida dati au second tour
elle compte proposer des alliances
d'arrondissement en incitant tout ce
qu'ils souhaitent la rejoindre autour
d'une majorité de projets qu'il soit
issu de la gauche des écologistes du
centre ou de la droite et on continue à
ce tour de table des candidats bien sûr
à la mairie de paris anne hidalgo la
maire sortante a voté dans le 15e
arrondissement la maire sortante qui a
suivi aussi les mesures de protection
ce matin vous le voyez en se rendant aux
urnes protection bien sûr contre la
propagation du coronavirus anne hidalgo
qu'elles soient ou non en première
position ce soir on va le voir dans
quelques instants devrait appeler c'est
ce qu'elle avait dit en tout cas les
écologistes à s'allier à ses listes pour
faire bloc face aux candidatures
notamment des républicains et de la
république en marche
alors justement thomas bonnin on vous
rejoins pour avoir les dernières
estimations concernant notamment la
capitale paris oui elles viennent de
nous parvenir ses estimations et donc
selon les premiers chiffres qui nous
arrivent
anne hidalgo la maire sortante serait
largement en tête avec un peu plus de
30% des suffrages en deuxième position
se serait donc rachida dati qui récolte
aurait selon les premières estimations
22% suivi donc par agnès buzyn 17 6%
selon les estimations pour l'ancien
ministre de la santé david d'élire le
candidat d'europe écologie les verts
seraient lui estimé à 11 6% des
suffrages
on notera enfin les scores de cédric
villani le dissident candidat dissident
de la république en marche qui
récolterait 6 7%
et enfin danielle simonnet tête de liste
la france insoumise en compagnie de
vikash dhorassoo récolterez pour sa part
5 % des suffrages on verra donc ce qu'il
se passera dans cet entre-deux-tours un
peu spécial évidemment puisque la tenue
de ce second tour
reste désormais à confirmer merci
beaucoup thomas bonne et on vous
retrouve bien entendu tout au long de
cette édition spéciale et pour en parler
stéphane rozès président de cap ce
enseignant à sciences po et hec est avec
nous par téléphone stéphane rozès
bonsoir bonsoir
alors pour une peau une première
réaction peut-être anne hidalgo donc en
tête avec une estimation à 30% des voix
suivi de rachida dati puis d'agnès busan
avec 17,6 pour cent
elle dévoile une réaction à ces
premières estimations stéphane rozès
chaque quart
une finale est évidemment un k 5 kg et
charnelle or ici par des enjeux locaux
ou la paix ou tanchoux et est donc là
effectivement sur paris nous sommes face
à cette situation assez paradoxale à 60
% des parisiens ne souhaitait pas la
réflexion d'anne hidalgo mais elle a pu
profiter de deux phénomènes le premier
c'est au fond une opposition très tissés
entre les républicains des crachats dati
d'une part et d'autre part un camp la
république en marche départ difficile
puisque les candidats d'un candidature
griveaux ne faisait pas l'unanimité il
cédric annie et s'est présenté en ce
temps et puis il ya des écologistes en
amour ali d'alcon est en position d'être
en dépit de dames avec l'anru d'autant
que rachida dati n'a pas faire la paire
6 annoncée peut-être parce que la
participation en baisse
la peña qui est parce que son électorat
était plus un électorat de paris siens
âge ils sont inquiets
du corona fiant réussi des risques de
propagation peut- on y perd ou trois ans
et c'est un facteur que l'on va
longuement commenté merci pour cette
analyse
en tout cas anne hidalgo effectivement
dépasse largement ce qui avait été
annoncé dans les sondages avait été
créditée de 24% rachida dati elle était
à 26%
on le voit bien il y a un écart ce soir
et par le jeu des alliances finalement
qu'est-ce qu'on peut envisager pour un
second tour si tant est qu'il y à un
second tour selon vous et pickup y avoir
à partir de ce soir au fond de l'inconnu
essentiellement c'est que va faire
cédric titi est petit par sa taille
guingois d'al koud donc cédric villani
et pour partie un faiseur de roi mais
attaque où et quand même dans une bonne
situation parce qu'elle risque de
bénéficier
tu auras guillemant là où c'est possible
de l'es22 d'expédia pour l'écologie et
verts qui avec 11% fait un score
peut-être un tout peu décevant pour eux
parce que sa campagne avait été affublé
big peut-être un mot stéphane rosas sur
le score de daniel busan on se souvient
elle avait été envoyée à la mairie de
paris après ce qu'on a appelé l'affairé
griveaux 17,6 pour cent
l'estimation qu'est ce que vous en place
est bon c'était une tâche un peu un peu
pour elle on a moins de reprendre en pro
de rente une campagne de pachins grieco
qui sur le fond de la forme avec la fin
que l'on connaît ada était quand même
passé à cette désastreuse donc au fond
elle aura limité les dégâts tout temps
que quand même à gaza à renoncer à sa
fonction de ministre de la santé au
moment de l'émergence de la tribu
coronavirus
et donc elle risquait de subir au fond
une forme d'étonnement qui a déplu à la
chine sous ce poste elle a été néanmoins
favorite et par le fait que son
successeur a semblé je dirais faire
correctement son travail aux bambins
dans l'opinion publique nationale et
parisienne le corner qui se tenait un
vrai sujet de préoccupation le même
corps navire vie ce qui entraîne il
avait tendance à la principale leçon des
municipales hausse très importante de
l'abstention de 7 points puisque la
participation est dorénavant à 46% alors
qu'elle était à 60% dernières
municipales et donc là il ya un double
problème c'est que on te considérer que
la qualité des résultats ont été altérés
justement par abstention n'est pas une
abstention de nature politique
c'est une abstention venant de citoyens
ayant craint pour leur santé lors du
godet deuxième problème
deuxième interrogation d'exécutif ati
raison tort de matija si municipal de ne
pas les remporter
quand même une augmentation de
l'abstention de 17 points semble donner
tort à l'exécutif a fortiori tu fait
picornavirus le deuxième tour devait
être reporté à plus tard tout confond
six ans ça que vont retenir les français
son coeur dada photographique les jeunes
ce premier tour des municipales est à la
fois altérée
par fortes housse de l'abstention pour
des raisons sa terre et d'autre part
afida légitimité des futures mères alors
on ne sait et sinon ici pas de la
fonction de maire et se définit les
défis qu légitimité aucune confiance
d'une majorité de nos concitoyens
il ya néanmoins une prime aux sortants
c'est le cas souvent pour ces élections
municipales est-ce qu'il faut maintenir
les maires qui ont été élus au premier
tour est-ce qu'il faut maintenir ses
résultats et finalement recommencer
selon vous pour un poil pour les autres
ça semble difficile on va pouvoir se dit
le conseil de défense qui va être libéré
en s'orientant comme certains le pensent
père un confinement total décidé en
début de semaine prochaine à confinement
total on voit pas comment effectivement
il y aurait par report du second tour et
on voit pas non plus que des maires et
dès le premier tour comme par exemple
gérald darmanin et d'autres bien sûr
mais j'ai subi la con t'es tu ne sois
pas ne soit pas acté leur élection ne
soit pas acté mais on sent bien que au
total
tout ça n'est pas cette saison parce que
entre la triste activation du vote au
premier tour
latry stabilisation du poteau 2e tour au
fond de mode de scrutin à deux tours
c'est une sorte de rite électoral qui
est un tout petit peu comédie musicale
on ne peut pas impunément cassis
dynamique entre la dynamique de premier
tour et la dynamique de deuxième tour
donc tout ça est au fond très
insatisfaisant et zabeth revenir sur ce
qui a été sans doute une erreur du très
ancien
or on pouvait pas demander aux français
à la fois d'avoir des comportements de
retrait face à la pandémie du
coronavirus est à la fois faire une
exception dans ce rite électoral qui est
important dans notre pays que sont le dj
bad
merci beaucoup stéphane rozès d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur arte france
sociaux et on va faire tout de suite un
point sur les estimations avec vous tous
gabonais quels sont les derniers
chiffres des grandes villes trois villes
auxquelles on va s'intéresser tout de
suite avec quelques surprises pour les
estimations qui nous parviennent on
commence par la ville de bordeaux où
pierre hurmic candidat dans une liste
d'alliance de la gauche candidat
écologiste seraient en tête avec 35,9 %
des voix il serait devant nicolas
florian le maire sortant maire sortant
l'est républicain de la ville de
bordeaux qui récolterait selon les
premières estimations 33 4%
à noter le score du candidat de la
république en marche les estimations en
tout cas du candidat de la république en
marche thomas cazenave 12 9% et puis
c'était un peu la sensation dans la
ville de bordeaux philippe poutou
candidat pour le nouveau parti
anticapitaliste récoltes selon les
premières estimations 10,8 pour cent ce
qui lui permettrait de se maintenir au
second tour autres villes dont les
estimations nous sont parvenues c'est la
ville de lyon où là encore une assez
grande surprise par pour ces premiers
chiffres avec grégory doucet candidat
europe ecologie les verts qui serait en
tête avec 29% des voix il devance
etienne blanc le candidat les
républicains qui récolte ray 16 7 % et
enfin en troisième position yann
cucherat l'adjoint au maire gérard
collomb yann cucherat qui est tête de
liste la république en marche qui ne
récolterait seulement 14 9% des voix
un mot enfin sur la ville de grenoble
dont les premières estimations ne sont
pas revenues également où le maire
sortant eric piolle maire écologiste qui
a fait une alliance avec la france
insoumise et le parti communiste récolte
ray selon les premières estimations 40
86 % des voix il est devant
son concurrent divers droite carignon
qui ne récolterait selon les premières
estimations toujours 25%
merci beaucoup thomas on note donc une
percée des verts dans ce scrutin
municipal les verts qui je crois n'avait
qu'une seule commune jusqu'à présent les
verts donc qui confirme la percée qui
avait été annoncé pendant ces semaines
lors de ces sondages à lyon donc
situation favorable pour grégory doucet
qui avait également a le vent en poupe
pour cette élection
on va faire un point à nouveau avec
gérard gérard filoche syndicaliste et
ancien inspecteur du travail
bonsoir gérard filoche on a vu les
résultats à parier avec justement anne
hidalgo qui est en tête ce soir avec 30%
des voix un commentaire bah oui écoutez
je partage pas ce que vous a dit avant
moi stéphane rozès
pas du tout je crois pas qu'il faille
dire que le coronavirus à à polluer le
vote les tendances du vote existe
parisse et 32% pour anne hidalgo c'est
le double de madame buzyn
il n'y a pas de brouillage c'est lisible
c'est clair la république en marche a
fait tout le baratin à la publicité les
moyens j'ai même été appelée au
téléphone personnellement par madame
busin hier à débauche de moyens et elle
a même pas la moitié des voix de madame
hidalgo
donc c'est le vote est clair mon pareil
rachida dati à la 8 points derrière
madame hidalgo donc le vote est clair il
n'y a pas de brouillage et si je regarde
bien à bordeaux
ces listes unité de la gauche qui quitte
en tête
et si on regarde je regarde bien gérard
collomb à lyon qui va être battu il
n'est en bas bon si je regarde
l'ensemble de ceux des résultats que
vous venez de donner aux gens tirent la
conclusion que en marche coule partout
évidemment macron va pas vouloir
deuxième tour si un deuxième tour alors
qu'ils croulent partout bon il faut les
considérations sanitaires passe avant
mais il faut pas en profiter pour
ensuite vous donnez des votes plus tard
gagner du temps et ne masque et la
sanction
macron doit donner 5 milliards aux
hôpitaux macron doit retirer le projet
de casse des usa sur en chômage du 1er
avril
macron doit reculer
le projet des retraites et le retirer
moi je m'excuse si on dit que la crise
sédentaires que nous avons la salutaire
que nous avons c'est à dire la
catastrophe pandémique que nous avons un
préfet à toi suspendant tous qu'ils
suspendent le projet sur les retraites
parce qu'on peut pas suspendre que les
élections on peut suspendre le mal que
macron feao en même temps non j'insiste
où ça se paie parce que moi je suis
tellement ému à mon âge et tous parlent
les questions de la pandémie et je vois
tout évidemment il faut nous défendre
mais faut pas nous défendre en
manipulant le voit tout en prenant des
décisions qui empêche jeu edouard
philippe débattu la semaine prochaine ou
au second tour gérard en jeu à la
différence comme rosa simon diakité
d'audika je dis qu'on lille gérard jeu
des corps et les relations seraient en
reviens vers vous juste après merci
frage 9740 pourcentage 24 53 %
éric cattelin denu liste union
rassemblement national et indépendant
suffrages 2719 pourcentage 6,85 pour
cent alexandre chantry liste résistance
anti capitaliste suffrages 350 0,88 %
martine aubry liste lille en commun
lille en confiance suffrages 11830 de
pourcentage 29 8%
julien poids décidé pour lille suffrages
3512 8 8%
béryl benyoucef lice pour les
travailleurs pas pour les spéculateurs
suffrages 229 0 57%
violette spillebout tu lis tu fait
respirer lille six mille neuf cent
soixante dix sept mille 53%
voilà pour les résultats donc juste une
petite déclaration tout d'abord je
voudrais remercier les lillois qui m'ont
placé en tête ce soir appelé à près de
30% des suffrages et ce malgré
une abstention extrêmement fortes dans
le contexte que l'on connaît bien
évidemment principalement et
particulièrement dans les quartiers
populaires ce que l'on peut évidemment
comprendre vu le contexte dans lequel
s'est déroulé le scrutin
je me réjouis que les lillois est
majoritairement fait le choix de la
justice sociale et de la transition
écologique
je donne rendez vous aux lillois hausse
voilà donc pour l'intervention de
martine aubry on va retrouver gérard
filoche tout de suite en direct sur
notre antenne
alors gérard filoche peut être une
réaction martine aubry en tête à lille
avec des estimations près de trois ans
oui oui oui ça confirme le vote des
parisiens pour anne hidalgo
ça confirme les tendances en fait ce qui
assez que les électeurs ont cherché une
voix à gauche
unité de la gauche à gauche et la gauche
qui leur semblait le mieux placé où la
gauche qui s'était le plus uni ils ont
voté pour
c'est aussi le cas à grenoble c'est à
dire que les scores sont sont presque
sans appel la république en marche coule
partout que l'on peut être battu à lyon
c'est quand même pas rien filer peut
être battures oif c'est quand même pas
rien les bordelais peuvent être battus
également et donc on a une situation où
c'est pas le front national qui monte et
qui part en profite apparemment c'est la
gauche c'est mon rêve moi c'est d'éviter
le dialogue entre le maquereau et le pen
est d'avoir une issue politique à gauche
faut donc que la gauche sioniste au
d'abord pour le second tour quelle que
soit sa date il faut pas que le second
tour soit manipulée pour qu'on échappe à
la sanction du premier tour ne faut pas
que macron se donnait une partie à
rejouer
et donc là nous avons fait un geste yves
d'après les premiers résultats que vous
me donnez merci beaucoup gérard filoche
d'avoir commenté ces résultats en direct
sur rt france ce soir on va prendre tout
de suite l'est la direction de la place
beauvau le ministère de l'intérieur on
nous attend notre reporter mona hamoud
bonsoir mona vous avez d'autres
résultats à nous communiquer à présent
eh bien j'ai les mêmes résultats que
vous magali des résultats d'ailleurs
qu'il peut prendre avec des pincettes
car ils vont évoluer dans la soirée en
tout cas à paris vous parliez d'anne
hidalgo et bien elle serait largement en
tête avec 22 avec plus de 30 % elle
devancerait rachida dati agnès buzyn ou
encore à daniel belliard il ya également
ces chiffres de l'abstention qui sont
extrêmement impressionnant et record
avec 56% selon l ipsos contre 36,45 % en
2014 une abstention
au lendemain des annonces d'edouard
philippe 47 millions d'électeurs étaient
attendus pour voter pour ces élections
municipales notamment ce premier tour il
faut savoir que ce premier tour a
largement été décriée par plusieurs
personnalités politiques que ce soit à
l'opposition ou au sein même de la
majorité et qui demandait un report de
cette élection des français également
qui se sont exprimés sur les réseaux
sociaux avec ce hashtag je n'irai pas
voter et qui conseillait à tout le monde
de rester à la maison il ya également eu
l'appel du corps hospitalier plusieurs
médecins ont également lancé tiré la
sonnette d'alarmé ont demandé aux
français de rester confinées à la maison
tout simplement pour leur sécurité et
qui dit contexte particulier dit aussi
mesure particulière puisque dans tous
les bureaux de vote en france il y avait
des mesures de précaution il fallait se
laver les mains avant et après avoir
voté il y avait des linges et hygiénique
mise à disposition et il fallait
également garder une distance de
sécurité pour se protéger en tout cas
nous on a pu croiser quelques français
qui sont allés voter certains sont
satisfaits à des mesures de sécurité et
d'autres sont un peu plus inquiets et
écouté je tiens de bureaux de vote avec
d'autres collègues dont je pense que
c'est un devoir citoyen bon je pense
qu'ils ont laissés ouverts les commerces
de bouche
les transports sont ouverts donc je vois
pas pourquoi il y aurait plus de risques
dans un bureau de vote d'autant plus
qu'un certain nombre de mesures de
sécurité sont prises pour que les gens
soient pas les uns contre les autres ce
matin
je t'ai dit sur café n'était pas ouvert
non non moi je
bon tu avais j'allais dernière jeudi
j'ai été gravement malade j'ai failli
mourir donc l'année c'est pas pire 1
cette année
le virus qui courent c'est pas pire de
ce que j'ai vu je pense qu'on aurait dû
reporter ces élections purement et
simplement parce que il est
vraisemblable qu'on va pas pouvoir faire
le deuxième tour et qu'on va se trouver
dans une situation politique assez
inextricables pour aller voter je pense
qu'au fond tout le monde fait attention
reste à une distance d'un mètre et des
marquages au sol donc ils ont bien prévu
je trouve ils ont mis du de la solution
hydroalcoolique pour se désinfecter donc
surtout mon respectent bien les
consignes emmanuel macron qui a souligné
qu'il était important d'aller voter lui
qui est allé voter au touquet en
compagnie de la première dame mme
brigitte macron qu'on a pu apercevoir il
y à quelques heures qui était à pied ici
et qu'ils rejoignaient l'elysée en tout
cas toutes les soirées électorales qui
était censé se dérouler ont été annulés
est ce qu'il faut en retenir et bien
c'est cette abstention record qui a été
influencé par cette épidémie due qu'aux
vives 19 réez une abstention qui
commence déjà à faire débat à savoir si
elle a été favorable à certains
candidats ou pas je pense qu'on va en
entendre parler tout au long de la
semaine
merci beaucoup donne à nous de votre
intervention à vous étiez donc place
beauvau à paris et on va tout de suite
faire un tour à toulouse et strasbourg
avec vous tous gabonais de nouvelles
estimations qui sont tombés nouvelles
estimations qui semblent confirmer la
percée des listes écologistes dans les
grandes villes c'est le cas donc à
strasbourg où la candidate liste donc
europe ecologie les verts en alliance
avec les communistes
jeanne marseillan arriverait en tête
avec 26 7% devant le maire adjoint
sortant la république en marche et alain
fontanel pardon qui récolte rêve 1,6
pour cent des suffrages percée des
écologistes également à toulouse puisque
selon les premières estimations
c'est d'abord donc moudenc moudenc qui
serait en tête candidats la république
en marche soutenue par la république en
marche les républicains qui serait en
tête avec 35 3% devant donc le candidat
écologiste
maurice qui récolte ray selon les
premières estimations 28,3 pour 102
villes donc où les écologistes réalisent
un bon score c'est le cas également je
vous rappelle à lyon et à bordeaux où
les résultats se tasse quelque peu
l'écart entre pierre hurmic le candidat
écologiste et nicolas florian le maire
sortant les républicains semblent se
réduire
les deux seraient actuellement en tête
merci beaucoup aux abonnés l'on peut
noter effectivement un taux d'abstention
très important mais aussi une poussée
des verts ce soir dans plusieurs villes
pour en parler on va rejoindre tout de
suite m manon lebreton nombre des
constituants est élu rural
bonsoir bonsoir manon lebreton merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france un
commentaire d'abord peut-être sur cette
probable poussée des verts pour ce
premier tour écoutez non franchement je
n'ai pas très envie de commenter ces
courses de petits chevaux il me semble
assez sidérant d'assister à ce type de
commentaire là ce soir
à l'heure où on est dans une urgence
maximale et on devrait l'être en tout
cas et on a l'impression que ce petit
monde politique a vite fait d'oublier la
gravité de la situation
moi ce qui me frappe c'est c'est la
confusion totale qui ressort de ce
scrutin
la difficulté pour les électeurs pour
les pour nos concitoyens à se situer
dans dans cette confusion à savoir quoi
faire
confronté à des injonctions
contradictoires il fallait aller voter
tout en restant chez soi pour ne pas
prendre de risque enfin vraiment il
était absolument impossible de savoir où
était il me semble pour le citoyen
lambda extrêmement difficile de savoir
où se situer son devoir des citoyens
malgré tout l'abstention record massive
et historique qui s'est donné à voir
montre que la plupart de nos concitoyens
avaient conscience de cette priorité
absolue de la du danger que consid que
constitue à l'heure actuelle l'évolution
de l'épidémie
voilà donc mon jeu je crois que vraiment
notre devoir de entend que observateurs
politiques moi en tant que qu'elles
eurent rural vous l'avez rappelé c'est
ça aurait été d'abord et ça a été mon
cas d'appeler à ne pas se rendre à ces
élections
elle n'aurait pas dû se tenir je pense
que le gouvernement ait un certain
nombre de représentants politiques ont
manqué totalement sont passés à côté de
leur devoir républicain en l'occurrence
qui aurait été d'annuler de repousser en
tout cas ce scrutin un des temps plus
calme aurélie go vous attendez quoi ce
soir comme attitude comme parole des
candidats à ces municipales maintenant
le breton manon lebreton pardon écoutez
moi c'est il me semble que globalement
enfin si on est dans une situation qui
est la suivante c'est à dire que au
départ emmanuel macron et la majorité
ont essayé de d'instrumentaliser cette
situation sanitaire qui s'annonçait
d'emblée assez grave
je pense par exemple enfin souvenons
nous que il y à peine quinze jours
edouard philippe profitez d'un conseil
des ministres consacré soit disant oh
coronavirus pour annoncer le 49-3 sur
les retraites
donc on voit bien qu'en réalité la
majorité et une grande partie du monde
politique je le regrette mais je
constate c'est de ceux de cette
situation sanitaire
le cadet de ses soucis aujourd'hui et ça
et pendant longtemps un prétexte je
crois que la majorité
emmanuel macron se sont retrouvés piégés
dans cette attitude dans leur propre
communication optimiste hyper optimiste
en disant un coup aller au théâtre aller
en terrasse continue à vivre comme avant
soyez libres etc qui était un discours
absolument irresponsable et aujourd'hui
ce que je constate ce soir c'est que
finalement une grande partie du des
candidats des des responsables
politiques ont l'air d'avoir totalement
oublié le
le caractère exceptionnel de cette
abstention qui fausse la sincérité du
scrutin et qui devrait laisser aucune
hésitation sur le sort à donner à ces
élections à ce scrutin pour la suite
c'est à dire que il est évident que on
devrait aller dans les jours qui
viennent vers une annulation du scrutin
puisque le deuxième tour ne pourra pas
se tenir en tout cas j'espère que les
les mesures sanitaires seront tels que
on renoncera comme le réclament les
médecins comme l'ont réclamé les
soignants toute la journée aujourd'hui
que les scrutins ne puisse pas se tenir
car c'est faire courir un risque
sanitaire
d'autant plus grand à la population le
gouvernement qui veut réunir demain à
partir de demain des experts et les
responsables des politiques pour prendre
position à savoir s'il y aura un second
tour ou pas vous pensez que c'est
maintenant qu'il faut décider
il faut l'annuler tout de suite ce
second tour sachant qu'aujourd'hui le
nouveau bilan est de 127 morts et 5423
cas confirmés en france on
s'acheminerait dit certains vers un
scénario italien donc on sent un certain
flottement en tout cas dans la rapidité
vous le disiez de prendre des décisions
et bien sûr la seule attitude
responsable de la part de des politiques
et de nos gouvernants en l'occurrence
puisqu'il avait la main pour le faire
qu'ils sont si prompts à prendre des
décisions verticale est immédiate
j'ai bien c'était l'occasion là de
montrer que il était capable de le faire
pour suspendre ce scrutin comme je
disais dès la veille de ceux de ce
premier tour aujourd'hui je pense à tous
ceux qui nous regardent je pense à ces
responsables médicaux qui vont êtres qui
sont déjà mobilisés dans les hôpitaux je
pense aux italiens et aux espagnols qui
sont confrontés à la situation qui nous
attend probablement d'ici une semaine
maximum
à savoir cette saturation absolue des
hôpitaux on en voit déjà les prémices en
france
et on a affaire à des gens qui se
comportent comme si on pouvait se
demander dans cette ce que j'ai appelé
7,7 pour cette course de petits chevaux
se demander qui arrive un peu en tête ce
comme si on était dans une situation
normale il est évident qu'aujourd'hui le
la seule fille la seule attitude
responsable
c'est de renoncer à ces élections et
donc ça impliquera de d'annuler les
résultats de ce premier tour c'est
terrible de se dire qu'on a déployé tous
tous ses moyens toute cette énergie et
qu'on a exposé autant de concitoyens
alors que vraisemblablement il ne
restera rien ou très peu de ceux de ce
premier tour et pour finir je crois que
enfin je garde en tête ces mots
extrêmement forts d'un médecin qui s'est
rendu dans un bureau de vote pour
constater la façon dont ce se dérouler
le scrutin
c'est un médecin stéphanois je crois
qu'ils disaient vous compter les votes
et nous nous contre nous compterons les
morts et lien je crois que c'est
vraiment la phrase devrait qui devrait
résonner dans l'esprit de ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui responsables de cette
situation en ayant maintenu ce scrutin
et j'espère qu effectivement le second
tour ne tardera pas à être annulée
puisque de toute façon il est évident
que la situation sanitaire ne permettra
pas dans un contexte de confinement
s'annonce bientôt absolue ne permettra
pas de mener au bout de ce deuxième
merci beaucoup la non le breton merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur
l'arrêt dé france on va écouter anne
hidalgo la maire sortante de paris match
devant et dans ces circonstances si
particulière je veux d'abord remercier
toutes celles et ceux qui se sont
mobilisés aujourd'hui
depuis une semaine pour que l'élection
se déroule dans les meilleures
conditions possibles
je veux solennellement remercier les
parisiennes et les parisiens qui malgré
l'épidémie que nous traversons se sont
déplacés en nombre
au vu des circonstances aujourd'hui avec
une participation proche de 43% et ils
sont venus voter dans une très grande
discipline et dans le strict respect des
consignes appliquées dans tous les
bureaux
merci bien sûr aux présidentes et
présidents du bureau de vote aux
assesseurs à toutes celles et ceux qui
ont assuré la tenue du scrutin
merci aussi aux agents de la ville de
paris qui ont permis le bon déroulement
de cette élection
cet acte de civisme vous honore nous
honore tous il montre notre attachement
à notre démocratie est à ce moment
essentiel qu'est le vote ce dimanche
vous avez fait le choix dans ces
circonstances hors du commun de me faire
confiance
ainsi qu'à toutes les candidates et tous
les candidats de paris en commun il y a
dans ce choix la volonté que paris
demeure une ville où tout le monde
trouve sa place où chacun est protégé
un pari qui défend le service public
pour toutes et tous
un pari où on est attentif aux enfants
aux personnes en situation de handicap
et à nos aînés un pari encore plus
écologique est encore plus solidaire un
pari ou lorsque l'on sera sorti de la
crise
on respirera mieux on se déplacera plus
facilement à pied à vélo en transports
en commun
un pari qui se mobilisera pour aider les
classes populaires et les classes
moyennes à trouver un logement et à
boucler les fins de mois
un pari libre et tolérant où on porte
fièrement son identité et où l'on combat
toutes les discriminations
ce pari vous le voulez pour vous même
pour vos enfants et vos petits enfants
car c'est bien notre avenir commun qui
est en jeu dans cette élection
je vous remercie d'avoir choisi cette
voie pour ce premier tour
j'appelle désormais à l'unité et au
rassemblement des écologistes des
progressistes et humanistes de toutes
les femmes et de tous les hommes de
bonne volonté pour que triomphent
l'écologie les valeurs de solidarité et
d'entraidé que nous partageons unis nous
serons à même d'affronter les crises qui
s'annonce et tout particulièrement celle
que nous traversons face aux coronavirus
face à l'instabilité financière face à
la crise économique qui s'annonce face
au péril climatique
nous avons besoin d'unité et de
solidarité entre toutes et tous pour
protéger les plus fragiles face à cette
crise majeure nous devrons continuer
d'investir dans les services publics
être aux côtés des commerçants des
artisans des entreprises nous devons
soutenir l'économie parisienne qui sera
durement éprouvé c'est un impératif
ce sont les défis que nous relèverons
ensemble en tant que maire je serai avec
toute mon équipe mobilisée et aux côtés
des parisiennes et des parisiens pour
faire face c'est mon rôle
cher parisienne cher parisien paris
notre ville a toujours su dans les
moments les plus difficiles montré son
meilleur visage celui d'une ville
rassemblé uni dans l'épreuve solidaire
avec les plus fragiles est toujours
debout face à l'adversité vive paris je
vous remercie
voilà donc pour l'intervention adèle
d'algues offrit à remercier ce soir les
français qui se sont déplacés pour aller
voter dans la capitale anne hidalgo qui
remporterait donc pour ce premier tour
aux alentours de 30%
voilà pour les résultats des élections
municipales on va faire un point sur la
situation sanitaire bien sûr à présent
et puis j'ajoute à que le ministre de la
culture s'est exprimée 1 sur twitter il
est porteur du coronavirus vous le savez
et frank richter a lancé sa réélection
dans la ville de coulommiers en région
parisienne une victoire selon lui avec
58,85 % des suffrages
ah il est maire de la ville depuis
maintenant 12 ans et vous le disiez
magali le bilan du coronavirus
s'alourdit
france il est passé à 127 morts et 5423
cas selon le ministre de la santé
dans ce contexte les tribunaux français
seront fermés à partir de demain en
raison du coronavirus sauf pour le
traitement des contentieux est
essentielle à cette disposition s'ajoute
à celles annoncées hier par edouard
philippe
les la france est à l'arrêt après le
passage au stade 3 de l'épidémie de
corona virus tous les lieux publics non
indispensables sont fermés jusqu'à
nouvel ordre
et c'est la ruée sur les commerces
alimentaires voyez un reportage de
clément hospital les rideaux du
supermarché se lève à peine que des
dizaines de personnes s'engouffrent à
l'intérieur la peur du confinement
général et de la pénurie pousse de
nombreux français à faire des stocks
dans leur viseur les pâtes le riz ou
encore le papier toilette c'est la dèche
il n'y a plus rien on croirait que c'est
la panique c'est la fin du monde
il n'y a presque pratiquement plus rien
les gens ils s'acharnent sur les pattes
sur les gâteaux et tout ça mais
franchement c'est la dèche
on se demande s'il va voir vraiment la
fin du monde
j'ai fini par devoir le faire je viens
de prendre une dizaine de paquets de
pâtes alors que depuis le début je
critique cette façon de faire mais au
final j'ai pas le choix
hier j'ai passé ma journée entière à
chercher un malheureux sac de pâtes
j'ai fait cinq supermarchés encore moi
j'habite vers la place d'auteuil vers la
porte d'auteuil pardon est impossible de
trouver des pâtes ou les rayons
dévaliser les sauces les machins pour le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
bruno le maire pas de panique il n'y
aura pas de pénurie en france et pour
garantir l'approvisionnement du pays
les règles de recrutement de travail de
nuit et les heures supplémentaires
seront assouplies dans les supermarchés
aujourd'hui les représentants de la
grande distribution nous assure que 90 à
95% des références sont disponibles et
qu'elles continueront à être disponible
dans les jours et dans les semaines à
venir
il n'y a pas de difficultés en terme
d'approvisionnement en produits
alimentaires pour les français et n'y en
aura pas nous y veillons alors que le
seuil d'alerté sanitaire maximale est
activée le ministre de l'éducation jean
michel blanquer estime que plus de la
moitié des français pourrait être
contaminé par le coronavirus et pour
lutter contre la propagation de
l'épidémie
elisabeth borgne a appelé à se déplacer
le moins possible il faut limiter des
transports de longue distance au strict
nécessaire s'agit pas de circuler d'une
agglomération à l'autre ça vaut
maintenant ça vaut pour les vacances les
rues de paris se désemplissent peu à peu
alors que de nombreux commerces et
restaurants ont baissé les rideaux à la
sortie de son bureau de vote emmanuel
macron affirme que la vie minimum qui
permet d'aller se nourrit de voter elle
doit continuer et d'autres mesures
sanitaires annoncé hier soir pour les
restaurateurs notamment qui ont qui
n'ont pas pu ouvrir ce matin certains se
sont organisés et ne compte pas rester
inactifs vous allez le voir illustration
au coeur de la capitale où un restaurant
s'est lancé dans la vente à emporter
comme beaucoup il doit écouler les
stocks afin d'éviter des grosses pertes
financières
le premier syndicat du secteur se dit
solidairement engagé pour traverser
cette crise écouter la première chose
que j'ai faite c'est j'ai bien regardé
si la vente est reportée et la vente à
livrer c'est à dire les plateaux aux
livres et ne rentrait pas dans le décret
apparemment c'est un autre pas dans des
je dis bien apparemment parce que les
choses peuvent changer les choses
changent de jour en jour donc on a un
souci par rapport à ça
mais pour l'instant je vais faire de la
vente en porte et vous voyez on est à un
mètre des quarts et je vais faire de la
vente à emporter les gens vont commander
la carte habituelle qui est là et puis
on va leur faire ça dans des telles que
wayne et des plats à emporter et vont
partir avec ça qu'ils vont payer moins
cher bien sûr que c'est un restaurant
que moi en 35 ans de carrière je me suis
jamais retrouvé au chômage quoi donc ça
me fait bizarre je n'avais jamais pensé
imaginé même me retrouver au chômage un
jour quoi donc là et je sais pas
l'avenir ce que va donner quoi et
l'union européenne va limiter les
exportations de masques et d'autres
équipements de mes deux médicaux de
protection afin de garantir son propre
approvisionnement face à la pandémie due
nouveau coronavirus et pour gerald qui
injecte médecins urgentistes en france
il est urgent de limiter la propagation
du virus écoute elle même si vous n'avez
qu'un % de malades qui vont avoir besoin
de réanimation mais que vous avez reste
qu'on appelle un taux d' attaque c'est à
dire énormément de personnes dans la
population 15 millions pendant cette
hypothèse-là 15 millions jean michel
blanquer remise l'éducation nationale a
parlé lui de la moitié donc de 50% des
français donc 30 millions mais prenant
cette hypothèse base de 15 millions 1 %
qui nécessite de la réanimation sur 15
millions ça fait cent cinquante mille
personnes qui ont besoin de réanimation
or nos capacités sont de 15000 places en
réanimation ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'on pouvait prendre un dixième
des patients en charge
d'où la stratégie du gouvernement depuis
le début de cette crise de freiner de
ralentir d'aplatir cette vague qui
risque de submerger pour que cette vague
puisse passer plusieurs semaines sur
plusieurs mois éventuellement pour
pouvoir lisser les choses et que ces 150
mille malades si on part sur cette île
aux arts et potez l'appui savoir tous
une place en réanimation si vous les
prenez tous la même pour semaine vous
n'aurez pas la place si vous les prenez
sur une dizaine de semaines
on peut espérer pouvoir absorber ce flux
de patients et voilà pour le point sur
le coronavirus on continue cette soirée
spéciale élections municipales dans un
contexte extrêmement particulier où la
situation est grave en france avec 127
morts et 5423 qu'a confirmé ce soir une
situation qui risque d'empirer
on en parle avec florian philippot
presidents day
des patriotes et conseiller régional du
grand test oui bonsoir mon sort florian
philippot merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france est ce que vous étiez de ceux qui
ne voulaient pas que ce premier tour se
tienne
oui moi j'étais à la réunion avec coin
de la santé la semaine dernière j'avais
déjà rejeté je l'avais dit publiquement
en sortant à vos confrères j'avais
regretté qu'on ait très peu abordé cette
question des municipal je trouvais ça
assez dingue et mais j'avais j'avais dit
lors d'une intervention que je
comprendrais parfaitement que en suivant
les avis des experts scientifiques
on reporte le premier tour personne
n'avait rebondit sur ce sujet
malheureusement oui j'étais plutôt
d'avis qu'il fallait puisque ont passé
en phase iii et qu'il fallait limiter
les interactions sociales comme on dit
j'étais plutôt la vie qui évidemment
logiquement on reporte les élections
municipales
alors ce soir on est dans une situation
un peu surréaliste où on ne sait pas
s'il y aura un second tour avec des des
mères qui obtiennent une majorité
absolue faut-il maintenir ces résultats
là et faire une élection ultérieure pour
pour les autres comment est-ce que ça va
se passer selon vous comment est-ce que
ça peut se passer
bah écoutez rond les re convoqué à
matignon la dans la semaine sur ce sujet
devra les chefs de partis moi je vais
dire très clairement je crois que j'ai
bien compris que je ne serai pas du tout
le seul à dire cela qu'il faut reporter
évidemment ce second tour que c'est
complètement ce serait complètement
dingue de le mettre en place ce mois
d'ailleurs favorable confirmant le plus
vite possible total de la population
française ce que je pense que l'épidémie
est gravissime et que les comportements
des uns et des autres ne sont pas assez
responsables il faut donc aller vers une
situation de confinement total à
l'espagnole ou à l'italienne
bon pour les maires élus au premier tour
je propose qu'il soit élu on va pas
refaire l'élection ils ont utilisé au
premier tour très bien c'est le cas
d'ailleurs dans un nombre considérable
de petites communes françaises cela
permettra d'éviter de refaire beaucoup
d'élections dans ces communes là et puis
pour le reste il faudra tout refaire
puisque si on reporte l'élection de six
mois on va pas faire un second tour sur
fondée sur un premier tour qui fera
qu'on peut être mandaté que tout le
monde l'a oublié
donc je pense qu'il faudra tout refaire
pour les plus communes qui qui n'ont pas
de mère au premier tour ouais il est
possible que l'on s'achemine vers un
confinement total des français à
l'instar de l'italie vous l'avez dit
vous pensez pas que le gouvernement
français prend des mesures au coup par
coup on a l'impression que la situation
s'aggrave salle tous les experts le
disent sauf que les mesures viennent au
compte gouttes et faits dramatiques la
manière du gouvernement français ne gère
pas cette crise vraiment dramatique
moi je vous assure on était à matignon
le matin edouard philippe nous expliquer
qu'il était absurde de vouloir annuler
l'école pour l'ensemble de la population
française
le soir même le président de la
république intervenait à la télévision
pour nous expliquer qu'il allait annuler
l'école pour l'ensemble des volets sont
quand même donc on voit bien que ce
matin j'écoutais une radio du service
public
j'écoutais le ministre de l'éducation
nationale monsieur blanc caire nous
expliquer qu'il ne fallait pas reporter
les concours du capes et de l'agrégation
parce que les ailes et d'étudiants
s'étaient préparés ce soir il publie un
communiqué pour nous expliquer qu'il va
reporter ces concours donc on se demande
mais que se passe-t-il phare y at il un
pilote dans l'avion et est manifestement
il n'y a pas de pilote dans l'avion
alors déjà que l'épidémie en elle-même
le virus sont déjà très inquiétant bien
sûr
tous inquiet par ce virus mais en plus
on a un gouvernement français qui qui
semble être un canard sans tête qui
avance dans tous les sens sans savoir où
il va et ça c'est encore plus inquiétant
il faut aller vite pourtant on a eu
l'exemple de la chine on a eu l'exemple
de l'italie
on a pris beaucoup beaucoup de retard il
faut aller dans les heures qui viennent
vers un compliment total de la
population française avec des règles
extrêmement strictes ça sera désagréable
à vivre quoi que on pourra peut-être en
profiter pour se cultiver en lisant
et puis aujourd'hui il ya internet on
peut regarder des séries chaque fois il
ya quoi s'occuper on veut travailler
parce que le travail a beaucoup de
choses à faire mais ce sera quelques
semaines
et puis et puis ce sera efficace mais
hélas si on fait pas ça on va aller vers
des centaines de milliers de morts moi
j'ai quand même envie de dire à nos
compatriotes si on suit le scénario
actuel du gouvernement
on rêve on va vers des centaines de
milliers de morts je ne sais pas si les
gens vont se rendre compte de ce que ça
veut dire un mot peut-être sur les
résultats que l'on a vu ce soir avec la
cette percée des verts se maintient en
tout cas dans les villes du
rassemblement national c'est ce qui
semble se dégager
ce soir un commentaire je suis en train
de découvrir les résultats ici et là
sont déjà très arrêtées sont peu
intéressant parce qu'ils sont fondés sur
des chiffres très très faible de
participation donc c'est ça le problème
on se demande quelle est la limite et de
ses résultats mais c'est vrai que vous
avez raison il ya une poussée verte
qu'on pouvait imaginer
peut-être d'ailleurs un peu moins forte
que ce qu'on pouvait penser le rs oui il
se maintient dans ces villes mais
partout ailleurs est en forte baisse par
rapport à ses résultats de 2014 par
exemple 7% à lille et contre 17% en 2014
9% à sarreguemines contre 20% fin dans
toutes les villes quasiment ils sont en
forte baisse par rapport à 2014 sauf
dans les villes où il était présent et
pour le reste j'attends de voir les
résultats j'attends évidemment de voir
pour paris également j'aurais aimé
j'espère que ce sera le cas que rachida
dati arrivent en tête au premier tour
merci beaucoup florian philippot d'avoir
répondu en direct à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes président des
patriotes conseiller
lional du grand test on va tout de suite
faire le point avec notre reporter mona
mou dès lors au ministère de l'intérieur
mona bonsoir alors la première
information du jour c'est le de ces
municipales ans et le taux de
participation qui est en chute libre
exactement il est ce taux de
également le taux d'abstention qui a
atteint un record en tout cas avoisinant
les 50 4,5 pour cent c'est
impressionnant d'après en tout cas
toutes les différentes réactions
politiques qu'on a pu voir sur les
réseaux sociaux il faut savoir que 47
millions d'électeurs étaient attendus
aux urnes et bien cette ce premier tour
il s'est fait dans des conditions assez
particulières puisque plusieurs
personnalités politiques ont d'abord
décriée
ce premier tour en demandant un report
les français ont également se sont
également exprimés et manifester sur les
réseaux sociaux avec ce hashtag je
n'irai pas voter il a également eu ces
médecins qui ont publié plusieurs
communiqués sur les réseaux sociaux
incitant à les français à rester chez
eux et je vous le disais puisque ça
s'est fait dans des conditions assez
particulières
il ya également eu un ton assez
particulier a dans tous les bureaux de
vote en france puisque des mesures dit
elles ont été prises pour protéger les
électeurs il fallait par exemple se
laver les mains avant et après d'avoir
voté il y avait également une distance
de sécurité à respecter il fallait
amener ses propres silos des linges et
hygiénique avait même été distribués
pour les électeurs on a pu croiser
quelques électeurs aujourd'hui en pleine
journée
certains se disaient satisfaits de ces
mesures d'autres étaient un peu plus
inquiets et écouté je tiens le bureau de
vote avec d'autres collègues dont je
pense que c'est un devoir citoyen bon je
pense qu'ils ont laissés ouverts les
commerces de bouche
les transports sont ouverts donc je vois
pas pourquoi il y aurait plus de risques
dans un bureau de vote d'autant plus
qu'un certain nombre de mesures de
sécurité sont prises pour que les gens
soient ils pas les uns contre les autres
ce matin j'étais dit sur café n'était
pas ouvert non non moi je
bon ça va l'année dernière je grave
malade j'ai failli mourir donc l'année
c'est pas pire un stan et le virus qui
courent c'est pas purgé de ce que j'ai
vu je pense qu'on aurait dû reporter ces
élections purement et simplement
parce que il est vraisemblable qu'on va
pas pouvoir faire le deuxième tour et
qu'on va se trouver dans une situation
politique assez inextricables pas allés
voter je pense qu'au fond tout le monde
fait attention reste à une distance d'un
mètre et des marquages au sol donc ils
ont bien prévu je trouve ils ont mis du
de la solution hydroalcoolique pour se
désinfecter donc je trouve tout le monde
respecte bien les consignes ces manuels
macron qui a souligné qu'il était
important d'aller voter lui qui était
présent au touquet en compagnie de la
première dame mme brigitte mâcon a
d'ailleurs aperçu ici à pied à quelques
centaines de mètres d'où je me trouve
elle rejoignait l'elysée pour vous dire
que ce coronavirus eh bien il a laissé
des traces puisque plusieurs soirées
électorales de divers candidats ont été
annulés ce qu'il faut retenir c'est ce
taux d'abstention historique qui révèle
un petit peu l' angoisse des français
qui ne sont pas allés voter pour rester
chez eux
merci beaucoup mona mon âme ou dès lors
en direct de la place beauvau à paris on
va tout de suite retrouvé didier maïsto
il est président de sud radio
fin connaisseur de la vie politique on
va l'écouter 28 didier maïsto bonsoir
mon toit alors on l'a vu un effondrement
du taux de participation ce soir
l'élection municipale c'est l'une des
principales informations
dans ce contexte là quelles valeurs on
les résultats les estimations ce soir
alors d'abord je ne commenterai
évidemment pas les résultats
parce que ces résultats n'ont aucune
valeur et le mot qu'il est venu toute la
soirée c'est surréaliste
surréaliste on est en train de commenter
l'élection municipale dans tous les gens
sensés avaient averti qu'ils aient
qu'elle ne devait pas se tenir
le corps médical dans son ensemble et
pas n'importe qui un les chefs de
services des hôpitaux parisiens les plus
en pointe sur le sujet au nom dans cessé
d'alerter et là ce soir comme des
playmobil vous avez tous les étudie ce
qui nous tue c'est le comité qui sont
ici cette qualité scientifique
il ya les du gel et des gants enfin de
quoi parle-t-on
ce soit il ya une explosion des morts
parce que tous les gens étaient dans les
parcs cédés des comptes c'est la fête
sortez se balader aller voter le tout le
monde tous les processeurs ce soir de
médecine disent que ça a participé de
façon active et galopante à
l'augmentation de l'épidémie il n'y a
qu'une chose à faire ce soir c'est le
confinement strict est totale et faire
respecter ces mesures
j'ai lu toute la journée des gens qui
disaient sur les sons les réseaux dans
les télévisions a mais il ya plus de il
n'y a pas plus de risques il ya moins de
risque de ne pas aller voter que d'aller
faire ses courses
enfin plus et plus dans mon pays et dans
tous les pays du monde ça fait plus
c'est pas qu'on va pas ajouter du
désordre et de l'épidémie à laquelle
allait à l'épidémie vente à un moment
c'est juste surréaliste je ne comprends
pas qu'on le discute on discute encore
de ces j'ai entendu à l'instant anne
hidalgo qui appelle qui se félicite
d'être en tête etc
mais c'est c'est indécent surréaliste gg
j'ose le mot ces criminels maintenant il
faut que tout le monde se ressaisissent
que la classe politique se re se
ressaisissent et dès demain déclare le
confinement strict et que tout le monde
reste chez soi c'est ainsi qu'on a qu'on
pourra lutter contre la maladie contre
l'épidémie il ya 127 morts déclarés en
france ce soir situation extrêmement
catastrophique en italie on
s'acheminerait vers à un scénario à
l'italienne en france et ce que disent
les épidémiologistes
vous pensez que les français ne sont pas
suffisamment
disciplinés finalement ou est ce que
c'est la confusion du gouvernement qui
fait que les français ne prennent pas
l'ampleur du problème
si vous voulez il ya quand même une
confusion gouvernementale
le problème depuis depuis quelques jours
le gouvernement ne cesse de vous dire
que ces scientifiques qui est un comité
scientifique et yanis
il a peut-être ça un peu comme un
entrain ces scientifiques les
scientifiques
bon le problème si vous voulez c'est que
les vrais scientifiques les gens avertis
et serra n'ont cessé d'avertir et n'ont
cessé de tirer la sonnette d'alarmé en
disant il faut pas que ces élections
soutiennent ils l'ont dit un peu plus
fort ce soir parce que bon le processus
était enclenché qui voulait pas affoler
la population
si vous dites aux gens écoutent et
dormez braves gens la situation en gérer
il ya un comité et c'est la seule chose
qu'on sait en termes des prêts
d'épidémiologie en terme d'épidémie
moi je suis pas scientifique mais je
m'entoure de gens autorisés à parler à
réfléchir
la seule chose que l'on sait faire et on
sait bien le faire c'est beau d'équipé
donc c'est pas nouveau on n'a pas
découvert sain entre avant-hier et
aujourd'hui on savait exactement le la
montée de la courbe
on savait exactement à quelques à
quelques dizaines de cette même unité de
personnes
quelles seraient les résultats et
quelles seraient les chiffres ce soir
c'est pas que cette épidémie ne s'est
pas que ce virus est particulièrement
nocifs
on va s'en sortir je veux pas non plus
affoler les gens il faut bien comprendre
comment ça fonctionne
c'est à dire que plus on prend moins en
prend des mesures adaptées plus le petit
sera rapide et au foot bien comprendre
ça il ya une capacité de lits la
capacité de lits il faut pas qu'elle
soit saturé il ya un certain nombre de
respirateurs parce que comment on en
meurt ça fait des complications
respiratoires
je vais pas rentrer dans les détails en
tant qu on meurt par étouffement dans si
les lits sont saturés
si les gens qui peuvent être sauvées ne
peuvent pas bénéficier de respirateur
artificiel
ils vont mourir c'est aussi simple que
cela et c'est vraiment indécent de voir
aujourd'hui les verts les jaunes et
bleus les rouges
compter les points dans une élection qui
n'aurait pas dû avoir lieu qui est
indécente en la maison brûle comme
dirait l'autre et on regarde ailleurs
et ce soir tout le monde se félicite que
la démocratie a été sauvé et c'est que
les gestes essentiels ont été assurés
c'est pas du tout le cas parce que quand
vous avez autant de gens qui vont voter
de mettre de façon inconséquente on ne
peut pas respecter toutes les consignes
de sécurité
il ya des pleins de bureaux dans le sud
mais tu n'es pas que ça ne va pas
simplement que dans le sud à marseille
et ailleurs où il n'y avait pas de gand
où il y avait pas de deux dispositifs de
gel ou les respects les gestes barrières
n'étaient pas respectées mais c'est
inhérent à tout déplacement massif tout
le monde peut comprendre ça donc il est
temps que les gens se reprennent parle
d'autre chose abandonne cette idée
mortifère le deuxième tour je pense que
de toute façon on y va et maintenant
c'est une course contre la montre il
faut que chacun
c'est terrible c'est insupportable c'est
compliqué on est un peuple social on
envie de faire la fête pendant quinze
jours trois semaines 1 - le temps qu'il
faudra il faut se discipliner il faut se
discipliner et ne pas y rester chez soi
ne pas voir de monde parce que je
j'entends aussi comme un leitmotiv
le virus circule le virus non le virus
ne circule pas le ce sont les personnes
qui circulent et ce sont les personnes
qui peuvent en contaminer d'autres
d'ailleurs le premier ministre l'air
dont le premier ministre l'a dit
d'ailleurs il a dit ce n'est pas le
virus qui circule ce sont les personnes
qui circulent donc on a du mal à le
problème maintenant le problème c'est
qu'ils disent ils disent on ne demande
pas au premier ministre au président la
république d'être des commentateurs de
la vie politique
on leur demande pas de consulter les
partis politiques gérard larcher les
républicains le rassemblement national
et tous les autres partis politiques
maintenant tout le monde le sait le
monde médical le sait on a l'exemple de
la chine on a l'exemple de l'italie à
nos frontières l'italie c'est nous les
italiens c'est nous c'est la main c'est
à peu près le même pays est juste à côté
on voit on voit les courbes elles elles
progressent exactement de la même
manière
donc c'est pas comme si on ne savait pas
tout le monde je sais donc maintenant
dès demain qu'il faut agir pour arrêter
d'attendre merci beaucoup didier maïsto
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur rt
france ce soir
alors thomas bonnet ce soir la question
qui s'est posée c'est faut-il reporter
le second tour de ces élections
municipales municipal et beaucoup en
politique on dit oui oui beaucoup de nos
hommes et femmes politiques semblent
aujourd'hui donner leur avis sur le fait
qu'il ne faut pas donc qu'il y ait de
deuxième tour pour ces élections
municipales c'est le cas par exemple de
yannick jadot d'europe écologie les
verts ou encore départ du parti radical
de gauche qui a fait savoir sur les
réseaux sociaux qui ne tenait pas à ce
qu'il y ait un second tour dans le
contexte actuel c'est le cas également
de marine le pen qui a expliqué qu'elle
ne souhaitait pas qu'un second tour se
tienne mais qu'en revanche il fallait
que les candidats qui ont gagné au
premier tour puissent voir leur victoire
maintenu vous propose d'écouter la
présidente du rassemblement national
compte tenu des témoignages qui
remontent de tous les services
hospitaliers et de l'expérience que nous
devons tirer de la situation chez nos
voisins le second tour n'aura
manifestement pas lieu compte tenu de
l'aggravation prévisible de l'épidémie
il faut donc considérer comme acquise
les nombreuses élections qui ont vu les
candidats être élu au premier tour et
reporter les autres qui devront se tenir
dans quelques mois quand l'épidémie sera
jugulé fait que ce deuxième tour ne doit
pas se tenir plusieurs arguments
évidemment il ya la crise sanitaire
actuelle on comprend que c'est compliqué
d'organiser les élections il ya
peut-être des enjeux plus importants
c'est en tout cas ce que semble dire un
certain nombre de représentants
politiques
il ya aussi la légitimité de cette
élection qui étend en cause puisque je
vous le rappelle selon les estimations
il y aurait entre 53 et 56 % de taux
d'abstention pour ce premier tour des
élections municipales ce qui est
évidemment un record pour ces élections
ce qui fait donc douter un certain
nombre de responsables politiques de la
pertinence de ces élections c'est le cas
par exemple de françois ruffin et puis
ce samedi soir il ya un certain nombre
de représentants politiques qui ont fait
part également du fait qu'il souhaitait
que cette élection soit reporté
ils ont fait part de ce souhait suite à
l'annoncé d'edouard philippe de fermer
les restaurants les bars et les lieux
publics
donc suite à l'aggravation de cette
épidémie de cordes un virus c'est le cas
par exemple de plusieurs présidents de
région et xavier bertrand président de
la région de france renaud muselier
président de la région sud ou encore
hervé morin et carole delga
respectivement présidents de la région
normandie occitanie ce sont des demandes
qui s'appuie également sur ce que disent
certains spécialistes c'est le cas par
exemple de rémy salomon il est président
de la commission médicale
d'établissement de l'ap-hp est lui sur
twitter il expliquait qu'il fallait ne
pas voter n'allez pas voter c'était le
message qu'il développait sur son compte
twitter on rappelle donc que edouard
philippe pour sa part qui s'est exprimé
ce soir a expliqué qu'il consultera en
début de semaine des experts
scientifiques pour faire le point sur la
tenue ou non de ce deuxième tour des
élections municipales merci thomas des
experts qui semble assez unanimes sur la
question en l'absence de mesures
radicales de prévention il sera
compliqué de d'endiguer en tout cas ce
virus on va en parler tout de suite avec
frédéric viale tête de liste de décidons
paris c'est la liste de danielle
simonnet la france insoumise dans le 15e
arrondissement de paris bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france
un commentaire pour commencer on ne sait
pas si on s'achemine vers un second tour
finalement à quoi bon avoir organisé ce
premier tour bah c'est un peu la
question qui se pose en réalité puisque
il ya véritablement quelque chose
d'anormal qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que
au prétexte de sauver la démocratie et
de vivre la vie normale la démocratie le
président macron a mis en danger la vie
des gens parce que c'est ça qui s'est
passé quand même aujourd'hui
comment est ce qu'on peut dire d'un côté
que concerne les écoles les universités
les hôpitaux étaient enfin pas les
hôpitaux les universités enfin tous les
lieux publics et dans le même temps on
convoque 44 millions de personnes dans
dans les écoles justement c'est
totalement incohérent
il ne fallait pas tenir ce premier tour
est d'ailleurs la sanction elle est là
il ya plus de 50% d'abstention on est à
56 % d'abstention c'est à dire qu'il
n'ya jamais eu autant d'abstention aux
municipales en france depuis 1959
cette élection est à 7 ce premier tour
est une farce il faut arrêter ça il faut
maintenant prendre les responsabilités
que chacun prenne ses responsabilités et
qu' il y ait au moins un second tour
reporté en face à paray sa part est
absolument nécessaire dans les
circonstances actuelles
frédéric viale le gouvernement a dit
qu'il allait consulter des experts qu'il
allait consulter les chefs de partis
politiques mardi pour savoir justement
ce qu'il fallait faire dans les semaines
à venir selon vous il faut prendre des
décisions tout de suite il faut pas
traîner dans ces affaires là on est
effectivement dans des dents des
élections il va y avoir là maintenant un
certain nombre de discussions qui vont
se tenir par rapport à des résultats qui
de toute façon son rôle pleinement fossé
du fait de l'abstention
donc il faut dire maintenant que on
reprend la question on refait les
élections plus tard alors effectivement
la question se posera de savoir si on
garde le bénéfice du premier tour ou pas
j'en sais rien je ne peux pas vous
répondre là dessus mais en tous les cas
arrêter cette opération là parce qu'il
faut arrêter de mettre en danger la vie
des gens on ne recommence pas à à faire
venir 44 millions de personnes dans
les écoles dimanche prochain ça n'a pas
de sens dans la situation actuelle et
c'est même quelque chose qui est sur le
plan de la protection des populations
totalement inacceptable mais finalement
il en va de la responsabilité des
politiques qui ont agi en concertation
avec le gouvernement pour maintenir ce
premier tour notamment avec le président
du sénat gérard larcher
à qui profite finalement là ce premier
tour parce qu'on aurait dit oui à 6,6 au
premier tour avait été annulé c'était le
parti présidentiel finalement qui était
mise à mal et qui avait intérêt à ce que
ce soit annulée donc qu'ils aient acquis
profite finalement le maintien de ce
premier tour selon vous je pense en fait
que le président macron a fait un petit
calcul qui consiste à essayer de passer
par dessus les élections municipales
puisque de toute façon elle était pas
bonne elle ne saurait pas bonne il était
prévisible qu'elle ne serait pas bonne
pour son mouvement politique et donc il
ya quelque chose qui nous sommes un
petit peu à l'oreille en dix ans mais en
fait ils vous lille a voulu faire en
sorte qu'on dise que ces élections sont
pas si importante que ça eh ben voilà
maintenant on est dans quelque chose qui
est quand même assez grave c'est que je
soupçonne quand même on peut soupçonner
le président d'avoir joué un tout petit
peu avec avec la démocratie d'une part
et avec la vie des gens d'autre part les
deux choses sont quand même assez grave
et on en a entendu le président de la
république ce matin expliqué qu'il n'y
avait aucun danger
je ne sais pas si vous l'avez suivi
emmanuel macron a expliqué comment il
avait fait pour voter en disant qu'il
n'avait pas été testée puisqu'ils
n'avaient pas de symptômes
c'est une attitude présidentielle ça
selon vous dont les parlers étant donné
la crise actuelle
non la seule chose qu'il fallait qu'il
fallait faire c'était prendre à bras le
corps l'intérêt général et dire voilà on
est dans une situation d'urgence
c'est son rôle de président la
république de prendre la décision
donc il convenait de prendre et plutôt
que de se livrer à des petits calculs
politiciens de dire au moment où il
fallait le faire c'est à dire il ya
maintenant plusieurs jours et voir une
dizaine de jours maintenant prendre un
certain nombre de mesures pour arrêter
cette épidémie je crois qu'en réalité on
a un gouvernement qui n'a pas pris la
mesure de la gravité de la situation
parce que ça fait plusieurs jours qu'on
entend tout et son contraire que les
choses navigue qu'on a toujours pas
véritablement ce que dit effectivement
ce comité d'experts scientifiques
donc là maintenant il faut que les
choses soient prises un petit peu à bras
le corps et que le gouvernement prenne
ses responsabilités au delà du
gouvernement l'ensemble des forces
politiques
merci beaucoup frédéric viale d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur leur défense
ce soir
merci et puis ma vie à lille la liste de
martine aubry obtiendrait près de 30%
des voix selon les estimations elle est
suivie par europe ecologie les verts
avec 23 points 5 % et la république en
marche qui récolte rey à 18 5 % martine
aubry qui dirige la ville depuis 2001 a
remercié les électeurs écoutez la je
voudrais remercier les lillois qui m'ont
placé en tête ce soir appelé à près de
30% des suffrages et ce malgré une
abstention extrêmement fortes dans le
contexte que l'on connaît bien
évidemment principalement et
particulièrement dans les quartiers
populaires ce que l'on peut évidemment
comprendre vu le contexte dans lequel
s'est déroulé le scrutin
je me réjouis que les lillois est
majoritairement fait le choix de la
justice sociale et de la transition
écologique et voilà non pour la
déclaration de martine aubry maire
sortante a lille on va retrouver tout de
suite notre reporter qui est place
beauvau au ministère de l'intérieur à
l'extérieur bien sûr précaution oblige
mona hamoud bonsoir monaco vous êtes
donc à l'extérieur du ministère de
l'intérieur
quels sont les résultats quels sont les
informations dont vous disposez à
présent
ah ah
eh bien on parle beaucoup de ce taux
d'abstention qui est un taux
d'abstention record avec 54,5 % du taux
d'abstention selon ipsos attention ces
chiffres sont à prendre avec des
pincettes ils sont susceptibles
d'évoluer tout au long de la soirée
cette forte abstention comparée à 2014
puisqu'en la 2014 sont avoisiner les
36,45 % de taux d'abstention et tout
cela on le sait évidemment avec cette
épidémie et coronavirus est également au
lendemain est des annonces du premier
ministre edouard philippe
on parlait des candidats et des villes
et bien anne hidalgo la maire sortante
de paris serait largement en tête avec
30,2 pour cent à la d'ailleurs tenu à
remercier les parisiens qui avaient
respecté et les mesures sanitaires
écoutez la je veux d'abord remercier
toutes celles et ceux qui se sont
mobilisés aujourd'hui et depuis une
semaine pour que l'élection se déroule
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
je veux solennellement remercier les
parisiennes et les parisiens qui malgré
l'épidémie que nous traversons se sont
déplacés en nombre
au vu des circonstances aujourd'hui avec
une participation proche de 43% et ils
sont venus voter dans une très grande
discipline et dans le strict respect des
consignes appliquées dans tous les
bureaux
ce taux d'abstention qui sèment le doute
finalement sur un second un second tour
qui serait normalement la semaine
prochaine edouard philippe s'est exprimé
d'ailleurs à ce sujet à savoir qu'il
allait consulter le conseil scientifique
écouter le jeu tient le bureau de vote
avec d'autres collègues dont je pense
que c'est un devoir citoyen bon je pense
qu'ils ont laissés ouverts les commerces
de bouche
les transports sont ouverts donc je vois
pas pourquoi il y aurait plus de risques
dans un bureau de vote d'autant plus
qu'un certain nombre de mesures de
sécurité sont prises pour que les gens
soient ils pas les uns contre les autres
ce matin j'étais dit sur café n'était
pas ouvert non non moi je
bon ça va l'année dernière je gravement
malade j'ai failli mourir donc
l'installer c'est pas pire à cette année
le virus qui courent c'est pas pire de
ce que j'ai vu je pense qu'on aurait dû
reporter ces élections purement et
simplement
puisque il est vraisemblable qu'on va
pas pouvoir faire le deuxième tour et
qu'on va se trouver dans une situation
politique assez inextricables aller
voter je pense qu'au fond tout le monde
fait attention reste à une distance d'un
mètre et des marquages au sol donc ils
ont bien prévu je trouve ils ont mis du
de la solution hydroalcoolique pour se
désinfecter donc je trouve tout le monde
respecte bien les consignes finalement
vous avez écouté les les français qu'on
a pu avoir cet après midi qui nous
faisait part de leurs sentiments qui
était plutôt mitigé car ce premier tour
et bien il a largement été décriée par
les français vous l'avez entendu mais
également par la classe politique de
l'opposition mais également au sein même
de la majorité qui voulait un rapport
des français qui se sont également
exprimés via les réseaux sociaux avec un
hashtag je n'irai pas voter ou également
des médecins qui se sont exprimées par
voie de communiqué sur les roses réseaux
sociaux pour demander aux français de
rester chez eux par mesure de sécurité
des mesures de sécurité qui ont été
appliquées également dans tout l les
bureaux de vote en france plus de 47
millions de français étaient appelés aux
urnes le président de l'ars et demi plus
tôt aujourd'hui avait indiqué qu'il
était important d'aller voter lui qui
était au touquet en présence de brigitte
macron première lame qu'on a vu ici à
quelques centaines du ministère dans
quelques centaines de mètres pardon du
ministère de l'intérieur et qui ensuite
s'est dirigé vers vers l'elysée alors ce
qu'il faut retenir en tout cas c'est ce
taux d'abstention historique et qui
finalement sème le doute sur un second
sur un second tour qui devrait
normalement se produire la semaine
prochaine et peut-être plus tôt même
être annulée merci mon âme ou deux pour
toutes ces précisions
on reviendra vers vous bien sûr plus
tard dans la soirée
et puis maïali au havre selon plusieurs
estimations et loire philippe est arrivé
en tête du premier tour avec 43 points
60% devant la liste conduite par le
député pcf jean-paul lecoq qui lui a
arrivé avec 35,88 % estimation le
premier ministre qui s'est exprimé ce
soir à remercier ses électeurs et il a
déclaré que le taux d'abstention à ce
premier tour démontre l inquiétude des
français concernant le coronavirus
edouard philippe a annoncé que le
gouvernement allait s'organiser pour le
second tour et que d'autres mesures
pourraient être prises et coûté 2 le
taux d'abstention élevé que nous
enregistrons témoignent cependant de
l'inquiétude grandissante de nos
concitoyens face à l'épidémie qui nous
frappe c'est long et c'est la raison
pour laquelle demain comme nous l'avons
fait jusqu'à présent sept en prenant
compte c'est en prenant en compte l'avis
des autorités sanitaires que nous nous
organiserons pour le second tour je
réunirai à nouveau en début de semaine
le conseil scientifique puis je
consulterai les représentants des forces
politiques
c'est dans une transparence totale
en prenant en compte les recommandations
sanitaires et je l'espère dans un esprit
de consensus républicain que nous
prendrons les mesures nécessaires
et puis les résultats paris également
très scrutées thomas bonnin oui les
estimations parisienne avec des chiffres
qui évolue évidemment tout au long de la
soirée
la tendance notable c'est le fait que la
maire sortante anne hidalgo arriverait
largement en tête avec près de 30% des
voix c'est en tout cas ce qu'affirment
les premières estimations elle serait
suivie de rachida dati 22% fluide agnès
buzyn 17,6 pour cent l'ancien ministre
de la santé qui arriverait donc en
troisième position neutre à la quatrième
place de david belliard d'europe
écologie les verts avec un peu plus de
11% et puis cédric villani le candidat
dissident de la république en marche 6 7
% et enfin danielle simonnet de la
france est soumise qui récolte ray 5%
dans la capitale merci beaucoup thomas
bonnet pour toutes ces précisions
et on en parle
au téléphone en direct avec fadila mehal
conseillère de paris
udi modem candidate dans le 18e
arrondissement sur la liste de pierre
yves bournazel de la république en
marche
oui je suis d'abord candidate au titre
de l'arrêt mais non pas de lui des
modèles mais voilà je vous remercie de
m'avoir appelé alors que dire de cette
élection je crois que ça a été beaucoup
rappelé c'est finalement le corolla
virus qui s'est invitée comme un élément
très déterminant dans des élections
municipales
et c'est particulièrement vrai dans
l'arrondissement du xviiie ou des
quartiers populaires ont eu un taux
d'abstention absolument record je crois
que beaucoup d'électeurs n'avaient pas
la tête à ça et compte tenu des
difficultés du contexte france notamment
bien sûr aux questions de santé mais
aussi la question du travail vous savez
combien dans cet arrondissement la
question du travail et est très très
importante avec un taux de chômage
endémique et puis bien évidemment la
garde des enfants donc tout cela
beaucoup perturbé en effet le les
résultats et le fonctionnement de cette
élection que ce que vous dites ça deale
amellal c'est que de toute façon même
les résultats du premier tour sont
contestables et vont être contestées non
je ne dis pas cela puisque finalement la
règle c'est que tout ce qui est exprimé
vos démocratique et donc moi je pense
que le président de la république a eu
raison de suivre l'avis du conseil
scientifique et des représentants des
forces politiques en en maintenance est
ce premier tour et je dis simplement que
en effet il ya eu sans doute des
interférences dans cette question et
c'est pour ça que bon là aujourd'hui le
bon résultat de premier tour de notre
maire sortant c'est un peu ce qu'on vous
râlez chaîne nationale c'est la prime au
sortant
que ce soit les gens de vitesse ou même
deux des républicains donc cette prime
au sortant est très très importante
surtout dans un contexte aujourd'hui où
les problèmes en effet de sécurité au
sens large
les gens avaient besoin peut-être de se
repérer par rapport à quelque chose
qu'il existait je tiens à dire aussi que
notre parti qu'un jeune parti puisque
vous savez qu'il existe que depuis trois
ans depuis l'élection du président macro
et que l'enracinement ne se sont pas en
une génération
dans dix huitième nous avons choisi donc
candidat d'agir puisque c'est pierre
yves bournazel et je peux vous assurer
qu'il a fait à d'excellents scores
puisqu'on en est à près de 17% ce qui
est très très notable quand on sait que
le 18e et quand même un arrondissement
de couches
ça va être compliqué de commenter ces
résultats puisque on aura probablement
pas de second tour
néanmoins vous vous parliez du
gouvernement qui prend régulièrement
avis auprès des experts mais beaucoup
d'experts disent il faut prendre des
mesures un radical de confinement ce
soir on le voit beaucoup payent même le
venezuela ce soir est en quasi
confinement pourquoi pas là vous ne la
verrez vous mais vous avez raison mais
les cibles et il faut pas juger
décisions à l'aune du rétroviseur
c'est à dire que mon moment et vous
l'avez bien vu ce gouvernement a joué la
transparence en l'état des éléments ils
ont pu disposer vous voyez comme la
question est très évolutive et donc
c'est normal que les décisions d'hier
peuvent apparaître complètement
inadaptés aujourd'hui aujourd'hui en
effet et sao soit vous avez entendu tout
à l'heure de votre reportage en que le
premier ministre avait rencontré réunir
le conseil scientifique de tous les
experts sanitaires et les représentants
des forces politiques je crois que c'est
à partir de là qu'il prendra une
décision parce que le risque est grand
que vous savez nous soyons accusé d' une
vision extrêmement autoritaire et faut
que absolument les choses soient vêtus
de façon consensuelle et appropriée par
les fonds par l'ensemble des français
c'est ça d'ailleurs normal que cette
étape puisse permettre le consensus par
rapport au renforcement sans doute des
mesures qui vont être prises
fadila mehal vous devez entendre les
inquiétudes les angoisses de
aux administrés dans votre
arrondissement dans ce contexte là est
ce qu'il faut à tout prix attendre les
nazis des experts des scientifiques et
pourquoi pas mais pas on nous le
reprocherait monsieur ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que les conditions qui
ont été mis dans taxe d'ailleurs je
salue tous les salariés les personnels
de la mairie du 18e qui ont fait un
travail remarquable et je peux vous
assurer que dans tous les bureaux de
vote dans lesquels je suis passé les
choses se sont extrêmement bien passé
c'est à dire que toutes les précautions
les mesures de précaution ont été prises
et il n'y a pas d'inquiétude
particulière par rapport à ceux qui
étaient là donc je le peux témoigner que
de ce que j'ai vu par contre beaucoup on
essaie notamment dans les quartiers
populaires se sont abstenus et donc la
peur sans doute est réel et il faut en
tenir compte mais vous savez nous sommes
dans un état de droit
et aujourd'hui il n'est pas possible
après avoir pris une décision majeure
est important politiquement qu'on puisse
revenir en arrière fond que les avis
soient pris elles sont que en effet tout
cela soit mis à l'honneur du consensus 1
un dernier commentaire fadila mehal sur
le comportement des français qui est on
les a vus aujourd'hui étaient
massivement assis dans les parent peut
être à bonne distance mais les groupes a
été plus pour eux pour le moins compact
moi je crois que la prise de conscience
est en train d'arriver elle se fait
difficilement notamment pour les jeunes
puisque il ya ce sentiment d'éternel
finalement et d'immortalité qui réside à
leur vie et c'est tant mieux parce que
ça leur donne beaucoup d'énergie mais je
crois qu'au fur et à mesure
quand on voit un peu les statistiques
alors c'est vrai ces statistiques
parfois certains considèrent comme
mortifère mais je crois que c'est
important de dire les choses aussi et de
voir comment la maladie progresse et qu'
elle n'est pas inéluctable puisque il ya
des barrières qui existent il faut
simplement les mettre en taxes
c'est une question la prod
responsabilité mais aussi de solidarité
parce que les jeunes doivent penser
qu'ils doivent aussi protéger les plus
âgés et travailler sur ce lien
intergénérationnel
donc moi je pense que les choses
arrive c'est vrai que un moment but on a
senti qu'il y avait eu un tournant avec
ce passage à la période 3
finalement et aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
fera très certainement discuter de façon
très très franche la façon dont on peut
encore améliorer ses barrières un
commentaire sur le score d'agnès busan
ce soir peut-être écouter c'est un score
vous savez la campagne a été émaillée de
difficultés vous connaissez le dernier
incident en date avec le retrait de 2,2
de benjamin griveaux donc ça n'a pas été
facile pour elle
heureusement les équipes étaient
constituées le programme était quand
même construit puisque je rappelle qu'il
ya des groupes de travail qui ont
vraiment consolider ce tous les axes sur
lesquels elle est intervenue
elle a porté une patte particulière en
fin de parcours sur la caution de la
solidarité et la question sociale et
notamment sur en effet le lien
intergénérationnel et la composition
qu'elle a faite par rapport au maintien
à domicile des personnes âgées
je pense qu'il va manquer du temps très
certainement mais ce que je peux vous
assuré parce qu'elle est venue très très
souvent dans le xviiie c'est que son
écoute sa compassion mais aussi sa
volonté d'agir pour transformer la
réalité très concrète s'en aille
d'ailleurs idéologie mais avec
pragmatisme a beaucoup en tout cas
permis à beaucoup de des lecteurs d'être
rassurés de voter pour elle la preuve
dans un arrondissement souvent qui est
très je dirais radicalise et parfois
cela l'a fait quand même un très bon
score puisque ces deux scores de la
moyenne alors que en réalité c'est un
parti nouveau c'est un parti jeune et
que aujourd'hui je pense qu'il ya tout
ce travail dans rapidement de
sédimentation qu'il faut faire merci
beaucoup fadila mehal d'avoir répondu à
nos questions ce soir en direct yves
cavaud aussi alors on my à lyon à partir
tout de suite en corse l'île fait partie
des régions les plus touchées du pays
par le coronavirus les électeurs ont
dans l'ensemble
doubler de vigilance pour se rendre aux
urnes certains déplorent malgré tout le
maintien de ces élections dans un
contexte de crise sanitaire majeure
égouttez laissez réactions dans le
bureau de vote d'action oui on y pense
bien sûr mais bon si on est raisonnable
et conduit les consignes je pense que
tout autre elle est correctement
ben j'ai tout prévu parce que je
préférais prendre vos propres liquide
plutôt que d'en prendre à ceux qui en
ont réellement besoin à savoir les
hôpitaux
voilà donc puisque les élections ont
lieu j'y suis mais je préférerais
qu'elle soit reportée la situation en
tant que professionnels de la
restauration je le trouve un petit peu
dommageable qu'on nous demande de fermer
les établissements et qu'en même temps
on autorise on autorise les élections
celles ci avaient un peu d'en passer
complètement à l'opposé
ces deux décisions qui sont un peu à mon
sens irresponsable et thomas v chiffres
qui nous arrivent de marseille
effectivement des chiffres qui des
estimations qui sont à consolider
puisque les choses évoluent il
semblerait que marine ma salle de la
liste divers droite et michel ribeiro la
de l'alliance de la gauche sont assez
proches finalement autour des 22 23 % ça
reste à confirmer stéphane ravier du
rassemblement national des récolteurs
est pour sa part que 18 9% des voix
reste à savoir maintenant si en cas de
second tour quelle serait la situation
dans cette ville de marseille ni les
reports marseille la ville de jean
claude gaudin qui ne brille plus de
mandat cette à cette élection
nous sommes avec patrick mennucci
conseiller municipal du parti socialiste
à marseille par téléphone bonsoir
patrick mennucci bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france un commentaire
sur les résultats à marseille qui sont
encore en ballottage et évidemment les
résultats définitifs ne seront connus
que tard ce soir ou demain matin
bonsoir magali bonsoir écoutez c'est il
affiche l'action il ya un devoir
l'héritier le jir club côté à l'afp m
s'il ya une deuxième tour et à un moment
il aura lieu mais il me semble que la
possibilité pour avec zico et avec
magali devrait permettre
delaby lillois emmenés vers un autre
chemin que celui absolument déplorable
qui était conduit par jean claude gaudin
depuis des années alors patrick mennucci
a marseille il ya eu des mesures
d'hygiène qui ont été prises comme
partout en france dans les bureaux de
vote
mais visiblement dans votre ville il y a
eu quelques soucis qu'est ce que
pouvaient nous nous en dira écoutez je
laisse aussi visé des bureaux de vote
sont les soucis que nous avons un style
c'est à dire une désorganisation extrême
des services publics et du service
public municipal
tu vois il y avait la plupart des
bureaux n'avaient pas de dégel
les conditions n'étaient pas en chine
etc
il faut peut-être que les français on
découvrir ont retiré leurs orteils
il s'agit gestion calamiteuse après les
effondrements de la rue d'aubagne mais
ça s'est pas améliorée depuis parce que
c'est les mêmes gens qui dirigent et ils
sont aussi incapable d'organiser
correctement
une situation qui nous est imposée pas
qu'on va virus que de 2,2 me nécessaire
d'être pourquoi n'y avait-il pas de gel
par exemple aidera le jeu parce que je
n'ai pas de réponse
la réponse m'a glissé dans la
désorganisation de cette ville ça vous
paraît fou quand vous habitez paris ou
dans n'importe quelle ville gérée par la
droite que par la gauche dans ce pays
les choses pas très généralement bien
d'ailleurs on le voit les maires en
sortant sont très souvent plébiscités
mais à marseille on est dans une autre
situation je pense que le résultat de ce
soir est aussi la fonction de cela en
tous les cas patrick mennucci beaucoup
demandent ce soir le report du second
tour de ces municipales quel est votre
regard sur cette situation ce soir et je
suis comme tout le monde je
pire et j'écouterai ce que disent les
scientifiques
je pense que ce soir il faut dire des
choses simples
il y a probablement soixante dix où 80 %
des communes françaises qui ont élu leur
mère parce que dans les petites communes
les choses passent au premier tour donc
je ne sais pas quel est exactement le
pourcentage mais je parierais que c'est
au tour de suzuki 10% et à partir de là
il reste que comme console de communes
qui doivent aller vers le second tour il
me semble il me semble que si un report
avait lieu avec une date certaine
organisation c'est pas le kers je m par
exemple eh bien on serait tous capables
de parieurs plus à mardi de fusionner
résiste puis datar mois de repas menu
campagne électorale c'est aussi jour
avoir ou une semaine avant l'adapter en
locaux à dire les cieux et ont mené sur
votre territoire national et pour les
mères qui ont été un élu au premier tour
faute il ment ils sont élus je crois que
les maires élus au premier tour sont
nulles mais je crois
vous savez on parle sur votre chaîne et
pour vous ce soir de paris de marseille
de lyon de strasbourg mais on parle pas
des 30000 et compte 3000 petite commune
de moins de 9000 habitants dont la
plupart ont validé ce soir leur mère
donc le droit de cela ce sont là ils
sont fatigués de faire fonctionner leur
commune pour les grandes villes où nous
avons besoin d'un deuxième tour
je pense que la situation la plus simple
c'est celle que je laime l'epr je pense
que demain nous aurons cette annonce
il faut quand même permettre le dis aux
listes de se fusionner ce qu'est posée
donc ça peut se faire mardi 18 heures je
réponds à chaud qui ont peu voté
d'hommes de moi ça n'a pas d'importance
mais pour vous cette élection c'est la
prime au sortant on le voit dans les
grandes villes
également effectivement dans par lemoine
alors les étudiants - j'ai parce que ce
n'est pas que après mon sens je pense
que c'est il ya une prime les sortants
c'est sûr mais il y a qu à main mon psy
manifestement il ne trichait de la
gauche
on nous avait annoncé une poussée des
écologistes à l'aller elle est
constatable simplement moi donc d'abord
là où il ya eu désaccord entre le parti
socialiste et les écologistes mais il me
semble que il ya eu le coup c'est de la
gauche qui a lieu d'un ce prix parce que
bon on le passera certainement par ron
cela rend pas moins content parce que
nous avons la situation du port en avion
les 5 m la république de marche a subi
la défaite
énorme alors les partis au pouvoir
seront désavantagés par les états
il y avait là nous avons bien même
décidé d'aider des personnalités je
pense à strasbourg nous annoncer la
victoire de monsieur comme danone ou il
est quasi même talonné par catherine
trautmann alors que avec le même pour
somme des voix alors que les écologistes
me promène sa toux 28 donc là la spatm
on va à la gauche et aux écologistes et
donc tout est bien à lyon
de la même façon à marseille où le
cabilat de la rmc 7 ou 8%
donc c'est une sanction vis des
ponts-de-cé mais bien sûr monsieur mac
on va ne va parler que du condat virus
était loisible à tous nous sommes
beaucoup que ce qu'ils entendent pas
vraiment ce que je veux souligner car
c'est la bonne tenue des plus grandes
personnalités socialistes soit françois
cuillandre bresse ce soit 6 mai robert
allan ce qu'ont annoncé battu par le
front national qui est élu au premier
tour
stéphane le foll qui sait 44% des voix
olivier bianchi s'il s'écarte pour ça
car montferrand nathalie appéré
johanna rolland et qui est bagdad je
pense qu'il y alla au parti socialiste
il a une espérance et puis n'avons pas
encore tous les chiffres de la région
parisienne mais notre ami hanotin est en
tête à saint denis
l'icc haroon a fallu avec cette console
alfortville david ross et délits avec
500 personnes
donc il ya pour vous la gauche a gagné
son pari de de prendre ces élections
comme une renaissance c'est un peu ce
qu'avait dit son représentant et la
république en marche a perdu son pari de
d'ancrage oui alors la république marche
a perdu son pari
dong rak de perry taurian et la
république à avoir il faut à ce qu'elle
mérite c'est à dire que quand on est
dans une situation où coco mais le
président républicain et les pratiques
des coudes personnes à un moment il est
sanctionné
donc il y a en fait il l'a poussée de la
gauche elle même tient là ou là les
républicains sont en la mairie garde à
l'ordre y ait de quoi l'état peine de
revenir une espèce de cellario oddity le
scénario gauche droite c'est d'ailleurs
ce qui va se passer à marseille nous a
parlé au début la république d'avoir
sont éliminés et donc ne fera sa propre
demande
godefroy merci merci merci belle en 1114
votre lourdes et mercy bonne soirée à
vous merci patrick ouart est de son côté
le ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner a félicité tous les
fonctionnaires qui ont permis ce scrutin
de se tenir dans de bonnes conditions
écoutez le je voudrais saluer
l'engagement civique et la mobilisation
de tous ceux qui ont permis aujourd'hui
à ce moment essentiel de la vie de notre
nation de notre démocratie locale
d'avoir lieu dans le strict respect de
nos règles électorales
je sais qu'ils ont fait de leur mieux
pour mettre en oeuvre les mesures de
protection recommandé par les autorités
de santé
je pense au maire et aux élus municipaux
je pense aux agents des préfectures et
des communes je pense à nos forces de
l'ordre qui se sont démultipliés toute
la semaine pour recueillir dans le
respect des règles sanitaires
les procurations en particulier des
personnels de santé qui étaient
mobilisés aujourd'hui des personnes
malades fragiles ou confinées pour leur
permettre de faire entendre leur voix
je pense à tous les citoyens qui se sont
rendus disponibles pour tenir les
bureaux de vote pour participer et
certains y travaillent en choeur à
l'heure je vous parle
osez paration de dépouillement et de
calcul des résultats grâce à eux tous
les bureaux de vote sans exception ont
pu aujourd'hui ouvrir leurs portes et
accueillir les électeurs
grâce à eux la démocratie ce soir l'a
emporté est tout de suite on écoute
rachida dati candidate ait l'air à paris
qui s'exprime à combattre cette épidémie
ils ont été mis à rude épreuve ces
derniers temps comme élu nous sommes
tous les jours aux côtés des parisiennes
et des parisiens aux côtés des familles
aux côtés de nos aînés des commerçants
des artisans de tous ceux qui se
mobilise en solidarité pour les
accompagner à traverser cette crise
difficile et pour leur apporter des
solutions pour soutenir leur activité
à leurs côtés nous nous relèverons de
cette crise je tiens également à
remercier tous les présidents de bureaux
de vote
les assesseurs et d'une manière générale
tous ceux qui ont contribué au bon
déroulement du premier tour de cette
élection municipale
dans de telles circonstances ce soir je
tiens aussi à remercier toutes les
parisiennes tous les parisiens qui se
sont déplacés pour venir voter
bravant les inquiétudes légitimes que
l'on peut avoir face à l'épidémie de
coronavirus je veux également adresser
mes pensées à tous ceux qui n'ont pas pu
se déplacer alors même qu'il l'aurait
souhaité je pense en particulier à nos
compatriotes âgées ou vulnérables
résultat de ce soir même si
incontestablement tout le monde n'a pas
pu aller voter confirme qu'il ya bien
deux chemins pour paris un chemin de la
continuité et du déclin de paris qui est
celui d'anne hidalgo ou celui d'un
projet profondément différent le nôtre
qui renoue avec les préoccupations des
parisiens avec leurs attentes concrètes
avec leur volonté de refaire de paris
une ville dans laquelle on se sent bien
je le redis je dis également à tous ceux
qui n'ont pas forcément voté pour nous
mais qui partagent la volonté de tourner
la page de anne hidalgo pour un autre
chemin soit possible le chemin d'une
ville plus propre plus sûre mieux gérer
plus unie dans laquelle on cesse
d'opposer les parisiens entre eux
d'ignorer des arrondissements entier est
de passer sous silence leurs difficultés
cet autre chemin est celui de la
conviction de la constance de l'énergie
est d'une très grande détermination
ma volonté de me back pour les
parisiennes et les parisiens est encore
plus forte ce soir j'appelle tous ceux
qui veulent le changement à me rejoindre
en écoutant que même et en garde en tête
qu'ils sont les seuls propriétaires de
leur vote
par respect pour les électeurs par
respect pour la démocratie
je demande au gouvernement d'indiquer
aux françaises et aux français dans les
plus brefs délais sa décision de
maintenir ou pas le deuxième tour
dimanche prochain
je considère que c'est au gouvernement
qui est le seul à avoir à sa disposition
l'ensemble des informations sanitaires
de pour prendre la meilleure décision
quelle que soit cette décision je la
respecterai
mais une chose est certaine les
parisiennes et les parisiens ne veulent
pas et ne doivent pas être privés du
développent démocratiques légitimes sur
l'avenir de paris pour les six
prochaines années
je vous remercie
rachida dati dont qui vient de
s'exprimer la candidate les républicains
qui arrive en seconde position selon les
premières estimations avec 22 % de voix
après agnès buzyn agnès buzyn qui va
s'exprimer dans quelques instants à 10
ans qui est arrivé avec 30 % des voix
selon les premières estimations à paris
donc 22% ensuite rachida dati suivi de
agnès buzyn 17,16 pour 6% pardon à paris
et puis à hénin beaumont le maire
rassemblement national steeve briois a
lui été réélu dès le premier tour
informations qui proviennent son
entourage plus tôt la présidente du
rassemblement national s'était rendue
aux bureaux de vote dans une ville
quasiment déserte marine le pen a par
ailleurs annoncé qu'il fallait
considérer comme acquise elle est
victoire au premier tour et reporter le
second compte tenu des témoignages qui
remontent de tous les services
hospitaliers et de l'expérience que nous
devons tirer de la situation chez nos
voisins le second tour n'aura
manifestement pas lieu
compte tenu de l'aggravation prévisible
voilà on va retrouver tout de suite en
direct agnès buzyn donc qui s'expriment
agnès buzyn qui est arrivé en troisième
position avec 17,6 pour cent selon les
premières estimations agnès buzyn qui
s'exprime ce soir je veux d'abord saluer
tous ceux qui travaillent aujourd'hui à
soigner nos concitoyens et j'ai une
pensée pour les malades et pour leurs
familles
je veux également salué tous ceux qui
ont permis que cette élection se tienne
dans un contexte exceptionnel les
assesseurs les présidents de bureaux de
vote
les agents du service public et plus
généralement tous les citoyens
la force de notre démocratie repose sur
votre engagement
je remercie également toutes les
électrices et des électeurs parisiens
qui ont fait l'effort de venir voter
aujourd'hui comme je comprends également
tous ceux qui ont fait le choix de
s'abstenir
dans ces circonstances exceptionnelles
je souhaite remercier chaleureusement
toutes celles et ceux qui m'ont fait
confiance
dans cette campagne de
premier tour singulière à bien des
égards plus de deux parisiens sur trois
ont exprimé aujourd'hui un souhait de
changement
il est de notre responsabilité de
répondre à ce souhait de changement
paris est à la croisée des chemins nous
le sentons tous il y à un certain nombre
de mesures urgentes à prendre pour notre
ville et c'est tout ce qui compte
face à l'insécurité et à la saleté il
est urgent de créer une police
municipale et de réorganiser la propreté
alors que les canicules vont devenir la
norme
il est urgent de cesser de bétonner et
de créer des espaces verts car cela
devient une priorité absolue
face au défi du vieillissement et de l'
isolement
il est urgent d'être à la hauteur en
créant par exemple un service public du
maintien à domicile
ce constat n'est pas celui d'un parti
mais celui des parisiennes et des
parisiens
alors ce soir pour répondre à ce désir
de changement
je tends la main à ceux qui partagent
les mêmes objectifs
ce qui nous rassemble est tellement plus
important que ce qui nous divise et
c'est évidemment d'abord le cas au sein
de notre propre famille si l'on veut
enfin apaisé paris il faut avoir
l'audace de ce dépassement
je veux être la mère qui n'oppose plus
l'est à l'ouest
les arrondissements aisé aux
arrondissements populaires
je veux être la mère qui ne demandent
plus de choisir entre sécurité et
environnement c'est en travaillant
ensemble et en étant rassemblé que nous
serons à la hauteur des attentes des
parisiens
et voilà donc pour l'intervention
d'agnès busin agnès buzyn donc il s'est
exprimé ce soir en remerciant ses
électeurs elle a détaillé le programme
qu'elle voulait pour paris
pas un mot par contre sur la situation
du coronavirus ce soir on va prendre la
direction de la place beauvau pour faire
le point avec notre reporter mon âme ou
dès lors monaco vous allez d'autres
informations ce soir sur les résultats
les mêmes informations encore elles
seront aidées les informations sont
définitifs à partir de demain qui sont
susceptibles encore de changer tout au
long de cette soirée ce qui est le plus
impressionnant en tout cas c'est ce taux
d'abstention qui est historique en tout
cas depuis et 2014 on était à 36 elle
vient réguler 45 % aujourd'hui on est à
54,1 5%
il faut il faut en effet dire que cette
épidémie est bien elle est extrêmement
elle est extrêmement importante
puisqu'elle a réussi à influencer les
résultats et les français qui ne sont
pas forcément aller voter puisque 47
millions de français étaient attendus
pour aller voter à ce premier tour un
premier tour qui a été extrêmement à
discuter mais avant cela je voudrais
qu'on écoute d'abord anne hidalgo qui a
tenu à remercier les parisiens qui ont
respecté les conditions sanitaires elle
qui serait largement en tête à la mairie
de paris avec 32% des votes écoutez je
veux d'abord remercier toutes celles et
ceux qui se sont mobilisés aujourd'hui
et depuis une semaine pour que
l'élection se déroule dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
je veux solennellement remercier les
parisiennes et les parisiens qui malgré
l'épidémie que nous traversons se sont
déplacés en nombre
au vu des circonstances aujourd'hui avec
une participation proche de 43% et ils
sont venus voter dans une très grande
discipline et dans le strict respect des
consignes appliquées dans tous les
bureaux
vous l'avez compris c'est une épidémie
qui sème le doute sur un éventuel report
du second tour je vous propose
d'ailleurs d'écouter edouard philippe le
premier ministre qui explique qu'il
allait consulter le conseil scientifique
à ce propos écoutez le
le taux d'abstention élevé que nous
enregistrons témoignent cependant de
l'inquiétude grandissante de nos
concitoyens face à l'épidémie qui nous
frappe c'est long c'est la raison pour
laquelle demain comme nous l'avons fait
jusqu'à présent sept en prenant compte
c'est en prenant en compte l'avis des
autorités sanitaires que nous nous
organiserons pour le second tour je
réunirai à nouveau en début de semaine
le conseil scientifique puis je
consulterai les représentants des forces
politiques
c'est dans une transparence totale
en prenant en compte les recommandations
sanitaires et je l'espère dans un esprit
de consensus républicain que nous
prendrons les mesures nécessaires
il faut savoir que depuis quelques jours
cette ce premier tour et bien il est un
sujet de controverse et il est
extrêmement polémique plusieurs
personnalités politiques se sont
exprimés ont demandé le report que ça
soit des politiques de l'opposition même
de la majorité gouvernementale qui
demandait aux français de rester chez
eux les français également se sont
exprimés sur les réseaux sociaux à
l'aide d'un hashtag du jeu elle n'irait
pas à voter est le corps hospitalier a
également tiré la sonnette d'alarmé pour
tenter de dissuader les français et qui
les laisser à la maison en sécurité nous
aujourd'hui on a eu l'occasion de parler
à plusieurs électeurs le conseil plutôt
mitigée certains étaient plutôt
satisfaits des mesures de sécurité
adoptées par tous les bureaux de vote et
d'autres se disaient inquiets
écoutez les je tiens le bureau de vote
avec d'autres collègues dont je pense
que c'est un devoir citoyen bon je pense
qu'ils ont laissés ouverts les commerces
de bouche
les transports sont ouverts donc je vois
pas pourquoi il y aurait plus de risques
dans un bureau de vote d'autant plus
qu'un certain nombre de mesures de
sécurité sont prises pour que les gens
soient pas les uns contre les autres
ce matin je t'ai dit sur café était pas
ouvert non graves maladies mourir donc
le stand
c'est pas pire 1 cette année le virus
qui courent c'est pas pire de ce que
j'ai vu je pense qu'on aurait dû
reporter ces élections purement et
simplement parce que il est
vraisemblable qu'on va pas pouvoir faire
le deuxième tour et qu'on va se trouver
dans une situation politique assez
inextricables pas allés voter je pense
que pour contre monde fait attention
reste à une distance d'un mètre et des
marquages au sol donc ils ont bien prévu
je trouve ils ont mis du de la solution
hydroalcoolique pour se désinfecter donc
choque tout le monde respecte bien les
consignes emmanuel macron qui de son
côté a souligné qu'il était important
d'aller voter ils étaient présents à au
touquet en compagnie de la première dame
mme brigitte macron ce qu'il faut
retenir est bien c'est que ce taux
d'abstention est historique du jamais vu
depuis des élections municipales et bien
il révèle un petit peu le climat
d'angoissé le climat de méfiance et
qu'il résidait au sein de la population
qui n'est pas vraisemblablement aller
voter merci beaucoup mon amour pour
toutes ces précisions
alors on vient d'entendre le premier
ministre edouard philippe s'exprimer il
est arrivé en tête selon les premières
estimations havre et comme lui
thomas ils sont dix ministres à s'être
présentés à ces élections municipales
oui avec des fortunes plus ou moins
diverses pour ses membres du
gouvernement ils sont trois à s'être
présenté en tant que tête de liste il ya
d'abord donc edouard philippe dont vous
venez de parler qui s'est donc présenté
au havre selon les premières estimations
il obtiendrait donc 43% des voix avoir
ensuite pour ce qui concerne le report
il n'est pas dit que cela soit un
résultat très favorable pour le premier
ministre on verra évidemment déjà si le
second tour se tient et puis le report
qui pourrait avoir lieu donc en milieu
de danses dans cet entre-deux-tours
autre ministre qui s'est présenté en
tête de liste et gérald darmanin et
selon les premières estimations à
tourcoing le ministre
de l'action et les comptes publics
seraient élus dès le premier tour avec
un peu plus de 60% des suffrages
même chose pour franck riester ministre
de la culture qui on se rappelle a fini
sa campagne en quarantaine puisqu'il a
été testé positif au coc u19 même chose
ils seraient élus dès le premier tour et
puis un mot enfin pour vous dire que à
coulommiers effectivement il ya un mot
enfin pour vous dire que sébastien
lecornu qui n'est pas tête de liste qui
est sur une liste
c'est un vernon dans l'eure pareil cette
liste l'aurait emporté au premier tour
voilà pour le point sur sur les
ministres on va maintenant faire le
point avec gilles casanova consultant en
stratégie et en communication bonsoir
gilles casanova merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france quel est votre sentiment
sur deux communicants justement est ce
que la communication a été bonne sur ces
élections on voit il ya pas mal de
cafouillage ce soir avec la situation
sanitaire grave en france nous sommes
dans une situation qui est complètement
exorbitant du droit commun jamais des
élections municipales ne se sont
déroulées pendant une crise sanitaire
d'un tel niveau et surtout pendant une
crise sanitaire qui a pris une ampleur
inattendue au cours de la semaine qui a
précédé les élections municipales
on se souvient qu il y a quelques jours
les partis d'opposition pressentant une
déroute des partis de la majorité
souhaitaient ardemment que se tiennent
ce premier tour des élections
municipales et puis progressivement à
mesure que le gouvernement a indiqué
qu'il le tiendrait on a vu
progressivement que ces formations
d'opposition étaient de moins en moins à
lente pour le tenir et qu'aujourd'hui
pour la plupart elle critique la tenue
de ce premier tour ou bien souhaite que
le second tour ne se tiennent pas c'est
une situation un peu difficile parce que
on a un gouvernement qui est dans une
double posture d'abord il est dans la
posture du
de guerre d'un pays en guerre contre un
virus même si ce n'est pas un ennemi
identifier le virus est un véritable
ennemi qui peut faire des milliers de
morts des dizaines de milliers de morts
donc on a un pays avec un gouvernement
qui est dans la position du général qui
donne les instructions que doit suivre
le pays pour se sauver
vis-à-vis de ce virus et puis de l'autre
côté on a un gouvernement qui a une
autorité politique extrêmement affaibli
qui s'est pris les pieds déjà lors du
premier conseil ministériel
extraordinaire sur le coronavirus en
concluant sur le 49-3 sur les retraites
ce qui était une faute politique
extrêmement grave
par rapport à la communication sur le
coronavirus qui du coup apparaissait
comme quelque chose de subsidiaire
utilisés pour faire de la politique et
donc ce double phénomène mais le
gouvernement et ses instructions un peu
un porte à faux
alors lui même a eu une difficulté à
exprimer clairement son avis jean michel
blanquer radi le matin qu'on ne
fermerait pas les écoles le premier
ministre a annoncé le soir qu'on l'ait
fermerait donc tout cela ça a contribué
à une petite musique qui crée une forme
de doute
alors ces élections elles se sont tenues
avec une assez grande participation une
égard aux inquiétudes qui pouvaient
exister dans la population sur le fait
de sortir de chez soi aller à la mairie
elles se sont tenues la plupart du temps
dans des conditions techniques et
matérielles qui respectait les consignes
de sécurité
mais évidemment une série de personnes
ne sont pas allés voter notamment des
personnes plus fragiles et on peut voir
à paris par exemple que cela a handicapé
la candidate des républicains notamment
dans des arrondissements où de toute
façon elle sera tellement majoritaire
que ces personnes ont pensé que leur
voix nallet jouer que marginalement
puisque à paris
les élections se font à deux niveaux
gilles casanova tous les français ont le
sentiment ce soir que de nouvelles
mesures doivent être prises pour
combattre le coronavirus le gouvernement
attend de s'entretenir avec des experts
attendent s'entretenir avec les
politiques des autres formations avant
d'annoncer une nouvelle décision
est-ce que c'est trop tard selon vous je
ne suis pas épidémiologistes je ne suis
pas médecin je suis pas même le
président de la république
c'est vous dire si j'ai du mal à
répondre à votre question je pense que
dans cette situation de guerre contre un
virus
le propos n'est pas de dire que le
général en chef n'est pas très bon je
crois que les français ont pu manifester
d'une manière ou d'une autre un certain
nombre de réserves à son égard mais il
est de savoir que si les français ne
font pas bloc derrière leur général en
chef dans cette guerre contre le virus
ils ont tout à perdre et comment
analyser le score de la république en
marche ce soir gilles casanova anton
crise en général un chef d'état fait
figure plutôt de rassembleur est ce que
vraisemblablement ça n'a pas été le cas
non plus
non parce que là on a tout de même une
érosion très profondes qui se joue sur
des mois et des mois de l'image du
président de la république et de son
gouvernement est qui
ce manifeste dans ces élections et je
vous dis on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure la
terrible bévue du 49 3 le jour du
premier conseil des ministres
extraordinaire sur le corps n'a virus
n'a a interdit au gouvernement de
bénéficier de cette image de changement
de situation du fait qu'il devenait le
général en chef
de la bataille de la guerre du pays
contre le virus il est apparu au
contraire comme hésitant entre celui qui
allait profiter de la situation et celui
qui allait vraiment mener la nation en
termes de communication c'est absolument
désastreux
merci beaucoup gilles casanova pour
votre analyse ce soir et de son côté le
ministre de l'intérieur et christophe
castaner a félicité tous les
fonctionnaires qui ont permis aux
scrutins de se tenir dans de bonnes
conditions écoutez le je voudrais saluer
l'engagement civique et la mobilisation
de tous ceux qui ont permis aujourd'hui
à ce moment essentiel de la vie de notre
nation de notre démocratie locale
d'avoir lieu dans le strict respect de
nos règles électorales
je sais qu'ils ont fait de leur mieux
pour mettre en oeuvre les mesures de
protection
recommandé par les autorités de santé je
pense au maire et aux élus municipaux
je pense aux agents des préfectures et
des communes je pense à nos forces de
l'ordre qui se sont démultipliés toute
la semaine pour recueillir dans le
respect des règles sanitaires
les procurations en particulier des
personnels de santé qui étaient
mobilisés aujourd'hui des personnes
malades fragiles ou confinées pour leur
permettre de faire entendre leur voix
je pense à tous les citoyens qui se sont
rendus disponibles pour tenir les
bureaux de vote pour participer et
certains y travaillent en choeur à
l'heure je vous parle
osez paration de dépouillement et de
calcul des résultats grâce à eux tous
les bureaux de vote sans exception ont
pu aujourd'hui ouvrir leurs portes et
accueillir les électeurs
grâce à eux la démocratie ce soir l'a
emporté benjamin morel maître de
conférences à l'université paris ii et
paix et en direct avec nous sur rt
france spécialiste en sciences
politiques benjamin morel bonsoir
bonsoir
cette élection ce soir fallait-il la
maintenir ou pas selon vous bah si vous
voulez il faut pas trop blâmer les
pouvoirs publics mais très clairement
parce que les vides
évidemment il y avait 1-1 prévision qui
était qui était importante mais
évidemment au vu des résultats qu'on a
ce soir il n'apparaît c'est pas évident
qu'il fallait maintenir à ce stade on a
quand même une abstention qui est
massive et par rapport à ce que des et
christophe castaner en excédent de la
une abstention qui est à peu près dans
les zones des dernières législatives
mais c'est pas tout à fait la même
abstention c'est à dire que l'abstention
législatives
c'est une abstention qui est même si on
peut le regretter et une abstention
voulue par les électeurs intentionnistes
là on peut penser qu'une grande partie
des électeurs ont été contraints par
peur par crainte de ne pas se déplacer
et donc à partir de là mon un scrutin
qui un est illisible et 2 est
fondamentalement problématique oui parce
que les français en général aiment cette
élection ils se rendent aux urnes
traditionnellement sur le sur un point
purement technique
est ce qu'un report d'un deuxième tour
est possible et quid du premier dans ces
cas là là on rentre dans une sorte de
création juridique si vous voulez on n'a
pas vraiment précédent le seul précédent
qu'on a deux reports entre les deux
tours c'est une élection législative à
la réunion dans les années soixante dix
et c'est évidemment locales partielles
et le conseil constutionnel avait validé
mais là on a quelque chose tout même
d'assez nouveau donc je serais tenter de
vous dire que déjà si on veut reporter
le second tour et de façon substantielle
il faut benoît donc il faudrait qu'elle
soit votée la semaine prochaine c'est
pas tout à fait impossible il faut quand
même qu'on convoquer le parlement par un
décret et il faut qu'ils se réunissent
objet de réunir tous les parlementaires
ont peu à voir mais si tout le monde se
met d'accord c'est jouable à condition
personne ne saisisse le conseil
constitutionnel donc il faut exemple
d'unanimité au moins entre les grandes
formations présentes au parlement donc
c'est possible
après une fois qu'on a voté la loi tout
devient relativement os x il n'est pas
saisine du conseil constitutionnel on
peut reporter unique pour le second tour
on peut reporter les deux tours très
clairement reporter uniquement le second
tour a donc plusieurs mois ça poserait
une nouvelle
vrai problème de sincérité du scrutin
parce que tout d'un coup et bien
évidemment les équilibres politiques qui
ont engendré le premier tour
n'engendrait pas forcément le second y
aura une période de campagne à rallonge
ça poserait devrait vrai problème en
même temps pour ceux qui ont été élus ce
soir premier tour pour ce qu'ils sont ce
soir au second tour est bien le fait
d'annuler ce premier tour ce qui pour le
coup serait une première
eh bien ça paraîtrait évidemment comme
une injustice donc à l'arbitrage va être
politique le droit à des pistes à des
instruments à ce stade ils sont tous
bancal mais la réponse ne peut être que
politique
et puis ça ne peut donner lieu qu'à des
polémiques finalement puisque
l'abstention va être analysé en faveur
des uns et des autres on s'achemine là
vers des commentaires à n'en plus finir
oui si vous voulez chacun peut
revendiquer l'abstention donc là il va
falloir voir un petit peu pour l'instant
on n'a pas tous les chiffres ou à
notamment par catégorie d'âge c'est à
mon sens le meilleur angle de lecture
est ce que les personnes âgées qui a
priori sont les plus sujettes à avoir
peur du virus se sont plus mobilisés
ou est ce qu'elle se sont moins
mobilisés tout ça n'est pas tout à fait
évident mais les classes populaires on
tue par elles ont gardé leurs enfants
enfin voilà tout le monde y va un petit
peu de son argument pour x alors cela ça
a l'air d'être plutôt dre donc là pour
l'instant on a juste des enquêtes
d'opinion d'avant ce scrutin qui montre
qu'en effet grosso modo les électeurs
des classes populaires qui sont
traditionnellement plus abstentionnistes
ont plutôt renoncer à aller voter
après il ya encore une fois une grande
une grande inconnue des personnes âgées
les études qui ont été faites et elles
sont importants de ces personnes âgées
parce que pour le coup elle donne par
exemple beaucoup à droite
elle va être beaucoup moins écologie les
verts quand on voit aujourd'hui des
résultats plutôt fait pour la droite
plutôt fort pour europe ecologie les
verts on peut se dire qu'en effet il ya
une question personnes âgées sur ces
élections
donc là on a des enquêtes qui ont montré
qu'elles ne se démobilisaient pas mais
ces enquêtes est daté d'avant le
discours des oies philippe hier qui
évidemment a changé la donne a changé le
regard qu'on a pu avoir sur ces
élections
très clairement en corne soit moi je me
garderai bien de tirer des conclusions
national de ce scrutin
au vu de l'abstention différentiel très
forte et au vu d'une
deux personnes qui ont pu se déplacer
qui ont cru devoir se déplacer et
d'autres qui ont eu peur de se déplacer
qui ont renoncé alors on se souvient
d'emploi du 49 3
au début de la crise du coronavirus pour
la réforme des retraites
est-ce que selon vous ça a pu finalement
créé une perte de confiance des français
vis-à-vis du gouvernement
cette façon d'utiliser le 49-3 au début
de la crise du corps vers virus alors il
est peut-être trop tôt pour le dire
néanmoins on voit qu'en effet quand on
prend les enquêtes qui sont parues un
tout petit peu avant le discours d'
emmanuel macron on voyait que on avait
un paradoxe c'est à dire que une majeure
partie des français considéraient qu'ils
étaient bien informés sur le coronavirus
et une majorité des français considéré
que le gouvernement ne leur disait pas
toute la vérité
ça peut paraître contradictoire se
voulait ces deux chiffres en même temps
il était fondamentalement
complémentaires parce qu'on voyait que
la crise de légitimité
eh bien elle allait d'abord aux
politiques qu'elle allait d'abord au
gouvernement même si à côté le
scientifique et bien été crédible et la
communication du gouvernement était
plutôt intelligente qui a tendu
justement a toujours s'appuyer sur des
scientifiques pour arriver à faire
passer un message
alors que la faiblesse politique et ait
lieu au 49 alinéa 3 en partie pas
seulement on a en grande partie tout de
même au vu du contexte pesé là on va
voir ce qu'il en est quand on prend
l'enquêté harris du soir sur le
gouvernement at il eu raison de
maintenir les municipales on voit que
très largement les français disent non
les quelques jours il était d'accord
quand emmanuel macron disais qu à les
maintenir
donc on voit que là dessus la
crédibilité du gouvernement aujourd'hui
sur cette crise elle est fragile elle
est variable et elle peut très
rapidement c'est scripté et en effet
cette question du 49-3 a conduit à des
l'origine des ce conseil des ministres
qui ne devait pas y être consacrés à
conduit à trajet lisez cette crédibilité
merci beaucoup
benjamin morel d'avoir répondu à des
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
maître de conférences à l'université
paris ii en sciences politiques et on va
faire un point avec vous tant abonnés
sur les grandes tendances à retenir ce
soir au vu des premiers résultats
attendant des tendances qui sont
évidemment à lire avec le prisme de
l'afp
sinon je vous le rappelle entre 53 et 56
% taux d'abstention selon les
estimations ce qui ressort en tout cas
c'est une vague verte but les candidats
europe ecologie les verts semblent avoir
réalisé des percées dans des villes où
ce n'était pas forcément attendu on
pense par exemple à lyon ou à bordeaux
évidemment il ya aussi à paris où david
belliard réalise un score de 11 6%
en tout cas selon les premières
estimations le maire sortant de grenoble
aurait également qui serait en tête au
premier tour avec 44 6% c'est pour cette
première tendance
les verts qui aurait donc réalisé de
bons scores
l'autre tendance c'est la prime au maire
sortant qui se sont maintenues à des
scores importants dans un certain nombre
de villes ont pas responsable au maire
de douai rennes qui semblerait tout cas
selon les estimations avoir été réélu
sur le cas par exemple à fréjus à hénin
beaumont à beaucaire ou encore à béziers
où selon les estimations qui nous sont
parvenues à quelques instants robert
ménard qui est soutenu par le
rassemblement national réaliserait un
score de 68,7 % alors évidemment tout ça
est à manier avec précaution puisque on
ne sait pas à l'heure actuelle s'il va y
avoir un second tour
il ya en tout cas de plus en plus de
voix qui s'élèvent contre la tenue du
second tour des élections municipales
marine le pen a pris la parole tout à
l'heure je vous propose d'écouter la
présidente du rassemblement national
compte tenu des témoignages qui
remontent de tous les services
hospitaliers et de l'expérience que nous
devons tirer de la situation chez nos
voisins le second tour n'aura
manifestement pas lieu compte tenu de
l'aggravation prévisible de l'épidémie
il faut donc considérer comme acquise
les nombreuses élections qui ont vu les
candidats être élu au premier tour et
reporter les autres qui devront se tenir
dans quelques mois quand l'épidémie sera
jugulée beaucoup de personnalités
politiques réclament aujourd'hui
l'annulation du second tour c'est le cas
même depuis hier soir en réalité depuis
qu edouard philippe a annoncé des
restrictions de déplacement avec la
fermeture des bars des restaurants et de
certains lieux publics depuis cette date
il ya un certain nombre de personnalités
politiques qui demandent l'annulation de
second tour c'est le cas notamment d'un
certain nombre de présidents de région
qui sont exprimées depuis hier soir
c'est le cas aussi du secrétaire
nationale d'europe écologie les verts en
dépit des bons résultats du parti
yannick jadot qui réclame lui aussi
l'annulation du second tour n'écoute
j'appelle solennellement le président de
la république à faire prévaloir en
toutes circonstances la la santé des
français et ceux dorénavant dans la plus
complète transparence je lui demande de
réunir dès demain matin les
représentants des forces politiques pour
tous pour tirer toutes les leçons de ce
premier tour et je lui demande
d'organiser avec cette ces forces
politiques leurs portes ce qui nous
attendons ce sont certainement des
débats sur la tenue ou non de ce second
tour on rappelle que lorsqu'il a pris la
parole ce soir edouard philippe le
premier ministre a déclaré qu'il allait
rencontrer l'espèce des spécialistes
je serai en début de semaine il a
également rencontré les chefs de partis
pour se faire un avis c'est un véritable
casse tête qui attend désormais le
gouvernement merci thomas il est porteur
du coronavirus le ministre de la culture
s'est exprimé sur twitter francs
cristers annonce sa réélection dans la
ville de coulommiers en région
parisienne une victoire selon lui avec
58,85 % des suffrages
il est maire de la ville depuis
maintenant 12 ans et le bilan du
coronavirus on vous le rappelle c'est
l'information est quasiment la plus
importante ce soir qui est passé en
france à 127 morts et 5423 cas selon le
ministre de la santé
dans ce contexte les tribunaux français
seront fermés à partir de demain sauf
pour le traitement des contentieux est
essentielle la france qui devrait passer
en confinement total dans les prochains
jours
information qui sera bien sûr confirmé
par le gouvernement une disposition qui
s'ajoute à aux mesures déjà annoncées
par et edouard philippe
hier la france qui est à l'arrêt avec le
passage au niveau 3 de l' alerte
épidémie au coronavirus tous les lieux
publics non indispensables sont fermés
depuis hier minuit et c'est la ruée dans
les commerces aliments
r comme le montre ce reportage signé
clément hospital regarder les rideaux du
supermarché se lève à peine que des
dizaines de personnes s'engouffrent à
l'intérieur la peur du confinement
général et de la pénurie pousse de
nombreux français à faire des stocks
dans leur viseur les pâtes le riz ou
encore le papier toilette c'est la dèche
il n'y a plus rien on croirait que c'est
la panique c'est la fin du monde
il n'ya presque pratiquement plus rien
les gens ils s'acharnent sur les pattes
sur les gâteaux et tout ça mais
franchement c'est la dèche
on se demande s'il va voir vraiment la
fin du monde j'ai fini par devoir le
faire je viens de prendre une dizaine de
paquets de pâtes alors que depuis le
début je critique cette façon de faire
mais au final j'ai pas le choix
hier j'ai passé ma journée entière à
chercher un malheureux sac de patates
j'ai fait cinq supermarchés dans le coin
moi j'habite vers la place d'auteuil
vers la porte d'auteuil pardon est
impossible de trouver des pâtes ou les
rayons dévaliser les sauces les machins
pour le ministre de l'économie et des
finances bruno le maire pas de panique
il n'y aura pas de pénurie en france et
pour garantir l'approvisionnement du
pays
les règles de recrutement de travail de
nuit et les heures supplémentaires
seront assouplies dans les supermarchés
aujourd'hui les représentants de la
grande distribution nous assure que 90 à
95% des références sont disponibles et
qu'elles continueront à être disponible
dans les jours et dans les semaines à
venir
il n'y a pas de difficultés en terme
d'approvisionnement en produits
alimentaires pour les français et n'y en
aura pas
nous y veillons alors que le seuil
d'alerté sanitaire maximale est activée
le ministre de l'éducation jean michel
blanquer estime que plus de la moitié
des français pourrait être contaminé par
le coronavirus et pour lutter contre la
propagation de l'épidémie
elisabeth borgne a appelé à se déplacer
le moins possible il faut limiter des
transports de longue distance au strict
nécessaire s'agit pas de circuler d'une
agglomération à l'autre ça vaut
maintenant ça vaut pour les vacances les
rues de paris se désemplissent peu à peu
alors que de nombreux commerces et
restaurants
et c'est les rideaux à la sortie de son
bureau de vote emmanuel macron affirme
que la vie minimum qui permet d'aller se
nourrir et de voter elle doit continuer
et voilà donc pour cette soirée spéciale
élections électorales qui était plutôt
une soirée spéciale coronavirus ce soir
étant donné la gravité de la situation
merci beaucoup ton abonnés pour vos
analyses sur ce plateau en direct ce
soir
et merci à vous olivier merci maïali
prochain point sur l'actualité ce sera
demain à 7 heures heure française nos
magazines continue sur rt france rester
avec nous excellente correction rt
france
[Musique]
il ya une première chose que je pense
qui est importante c'est que les états
que ce soit la france ou la belgique
reconnaissent cette situation reconnaît
ce qui a eu des adoptions illégales cela
concernait combien d'enfants
les chiffres exacts ne sont pas très
claires de plusieurs centaines donc
vraiment été orchestrée au plus haut
niveau en fait ce trafic d'enfants donc
vous avez été d'ailleurs toutes deux
victimes geparo ni l'amour que j'ai reçu
de mes parents adoptifs je sens que
cette adoption n'est pas totalement
légale quoi pour vous vous étiez adopté
de manière tout à fait le bateau à tout
est légal j'espère du fond du coeur que
notre procédure aboutira qu'un
concurrent se passionnera pour notre
histoire on espère être les pionniers en
la matière parce qu'il ya d'autres pays
qui sont concernés donc on espère
pouvoir ouvrir la porte aux institutions
européennes finalement
que veut-il dire en japonais et qui
comme mourir alors il veut dire qu'il ne
sort pas de chez soi tout simplement le
propre du phénomène hikikomori c'est que
on trouve des jeunes au japon qui refuse
de sortir de chez eux alors qu'eux ils
n'ont pas de pathologie identifiée dans
la nomenclature psychiatriques
aujourd'hui les qui comme or ils sont
pas des fadas de jeux vidéo c'est pas
des gens qui passent tout leur temps
dans leur chambre scotché à l'ordinateur
âge au jeu vidéo et c'est un
documentaire qui permet de comprendre en
quoi ce phénomène est vraiment
spécifique de la culture japonaise au
japon la pression scolaire est
extrêmement forte
mais les parents s'endettent souvent à
vie pour que leurs enfants fassent des
études et puis vous savez au moment de
la crise d'adolescence belle quelque
chose qui est remis en question
c'est une super méga crise d'adolescence
considérablement majorait par la
situation économique culturel social
familial qui lie au japon